what's up y'all as always welcome to the
channel hope everybody is having an
excellent night
wherever you may be whenever you might
be watching this
tonight
we're going to be responding to an SDA
Pastor by the name of Dennis
Priebe Mr Priebe is known for his strong
stances regarding traditional Adventist
theology particularly last generation
theology
I wanted to respond to this specific
presentation that he gave not because of
Dennis in particular
but as I've stated before I think things
like these that's why I picked the ones
that I do
provide great examples for Christians to
see to make a number of points and so
tonight we'll most certainly fit that
bill
one thing before we get started I'm
recovering some from some sort of uh
upper respiratory infection of sorts so
bear with me on that hopefully I don't
sound too nasally uh maybe some people
think I sound that way just naturally so
maybe you don't know a difference but
bear with me as I am recovering from
some sickness as well as the sickness of
a 19 month old and everything that comes
with that
but in this presentation
Dennis is presenting what are supposed
to be two Gospels
and he's going to represent them by two
trees
one of the trees he calls the mainstream
Orthodox Christian gospel
the other is supposed to be the
Adventist gospel
and it is Mr privy's claim that this
Christian Gospel tree has influenced the
Adventist tree
resulting in what some people want to be
a third tree that he calls Patchwork
theology
a hybrid if you will
but as we will see
there's one major problem
folks what do you think that is
what he calls the Christian gospel
and ain't the Christian gospel
so it is what I have labeled as the SDA
quasi-christian hybrid gospel if you
will because a number of the things that
he presents is just a big mishmash
Cornucopia of things nevertheless the
other reason that I thought this
particular presentation would be helpful
is because of how forthright Mr privy is
with what Seventh-Day Adventists
actually believe so you're going to see
he doesn't mince words he doesn't play
word games or beat around the bush
he's one of these old school types
and for that I want to thank him
seriously
um because he has no issue putting the
cards on the table stating it like he
actually sees it and letting the chips
fall where they may
and that's exactly what we need to be
doing not beating around the bush and
playing games and and all that stuff we
can make a lot more progress
um getting that stuff out of the way
but by laying the cards on the table
that includes stating that the Christian
church has a different gospel than the
SDA Church
and so despite his misrepresentation of
the Christian gospel he still recognizes
that adventism and Christianity are at
odds with one another on this area
so I appreciate that
so take notice of that
this man is willing to actually admit
what's really going on
but in the process of this comparison he
provides a number of things across the
board that will be particularly helpful
for Christians to see and hear to better
understand how you
can better be equipped to reach
Seventh-day Adventist with the true
Christ and his gospel which is precisely
why
answeringadvantism.com exists
this is the central Hub of our platform
please be using this folks
it is a gift from us
to you
it is where you can contact us share
your testimony ask a question donate you
can browse our extensive library of
question and answer content
before emailing questions please please
please check the library
you can come into these various
categories and search by category
you can come up to the search bar you
can search by phrases you can search by
topics you can search by keywords you
can search by anything to your heart's
desire you can type in parts of a word
anywhere that it populates it's only
going to give you a 10 in the drop down
if you want to see what else there is no
problem just hit enter it'll take you to
the whole library of anything on here
that contains the phrase contradict
okay
you can come on here let's say we want
to go to this one all the stuff that you
see in red all of that is hyperlinked if
you want to see the primary source for
it simply click and it'll take you right
to it and it gives you the breakdown
scripture you don't need to click you
can just hover it'll pop right up for
you and you can browse to your heart's
desire and content so please please
please
be using this because like I said this
is a gift from us to you and we really
want you to be using it get yourself
equipped to be able to engage with
Seventh-Day Adventists apologetically
because again they need the true Christ
in his gospel with me tonight
is somebody I'm grateful to Now call a
friend
Richard Foster
Richard and his family were former
Seventh-Day Adventists and he was
particularly into Dennis Priebe and his
representation of adventism when he was
an Adventist so I thought you know what
the heck he'd probably be the perfect
guest to bring on for this particular
stream so with that said brother thank
you for being here
oh sorry I do that every time I had you
muted just because I didn't want any
background noise to come through and
then I forgot to unmute you after I
asked the question let's try this again
welcome for being here or welcome uh uh
thank you for being here and welcome
anything that you would like to share
before we get into I I know that uh you
may not consider yourself anybody
special Richards contributed some stuff
to the answering advertising website uh
probably will continue to in the future
as well so really appreciate him but
anything else that you would like to
share for the audience that may be
relevant to tonight well like you said
I was really a Dennis freebie kind of
Adventist um
every Adventist it's a parent if you
start visiting and make friendships with
various Adventists every Adventist has
their own
celebrity Adventist Pastor they kind of
gravitate to
um their guy that they're in with you
know like some or like I have one friend
that's all about Doug Batchelor and
whatnot well for me it was Dennis Priebe
and his message of sinless perfection
and
you know you can get to the place where
you're not going to sin anymore Etc
yeah well he's going to get into that
tonight of course because that's Central
to his understanding of adventism which
I would argue is the consistent
understanding of systematic SDA theology
um but with that said let's segue right
into it here so remember folks like I
said he starts off by uh what he's going
to call the presenting uh the tree of
what's supposed to be the Christian
Gospel
um and I have labeled it for a specific
reason the SDA quasi-christian hybrid
gospel because both of these trees that
he presents
are informed by the great controversy
theme in the way that he describes and
understands the general things which you
you guys will see this but just a little
bit of backstory as to why I'm calling
it what I am so with that said let's uh
dive right into the first uh section
here
now and what I'm covering this morning
I am not going to give a bible study
this morning
this first one will be an introduction
this will be an analysis of two
different gospels you have two gospel
trees in front of you two descriptions
of the Gospel I'll be putting the very
same things up here on the screen so you
can see exactly where we are at each
point and we will look at what these
really mean what how to identify them
how to make an intelligent decision
about them and we will try to understand
how best we can determine which is the
true gospel in fact the real issue the
real question for today is very simple
what is unique what is special about
seventh day adventism what makes
adventism worth living for and yes even
Dying For What is the key point of
adventism and no it is not the Sabbath
no it is not the state of man and death
no it is not even the second coming of
Jesus Christ the heart and soul of what
makes adventism unique special and
different is its understanding Believe
It or Not of how person is saved by the
life and death of Jesus Christ how
salvation works now you say that doesn't
sound quite right because that's what
every Christian Church talks about how
to be saved how righteousness works but
I'm going to share with you why I
believe this is what makes adventism
totally unique and special all right
okay
so
it is a distinction worth dying for
so adventism is worth dying for catch
that folks
that's the proposition he's going to be
making that's the central thesis he said
of this presentation it's a series of
videos but this is the introduction one
where he kind of does an overview of all
things which is why we picked this one
but catch that this difference is so big
it is worth dying for and I appreciate
that he just comes out guns blazing and
just says the truth short sweet to the
point
and I actually think this guy's sincere
because he's actually honest enough to
say it like it is so he clarifies this
isn't going to be a Bible study he's
giving an analysis for us that's the
context
Richard what are your thoughts on what
he has said so far
well he absolutely shoots it straight
like you said before in the intro you
know we have to commend the guy you know
he's not beating around the bush trying
to do these uh PR statements like so
many Adventist pastors and leaders are
he's shooting it straight out there that
adventism has a different gospel and
that's what makes it unique you know
it's not the Sabbath
um other groups believe Seventh-Day
sabitarianism it's not the state of the
Dead you know other groups believe that
you you're asleep when you're dead but
uh it's this particular understanding of
how somebody gets saved which we're
going to get into here in a minute so I
won't jump the gun but uh
definitely
um what I found to be the case when I
was an Adventist is um
that's what it's all about is this
understanding of
basically salvation through internal
righteousness through
doing all these things this Progressive
sanctification is what's going to make
you righteous to stand in the sight of a
holy God
yeah
I the the first thing when I so I've
listened to this probably five times now
because I sent this to you weeks ago
when we when we were planning for this
all right and I'm just thinking myself
adventism is worth dying for
folks riddled think of the think about
the track record
riddled with failed and false Prophecy
from false prophets
William Miller Ellen White Samuel snow
who believed he was Elisha the prophet
before the second coming
cover-ups and fraud James White
embezzling
removing statements from Ellen White's
writings trying to find one right now
something she said about kids that they
forgot to sweep from the metadata of the
website so it still populates when you
search but then you click into the
letter and it's omitted well I found it
in physical form so I'm waiting for the
book to get here nevertheless
christological heresy
it was started by behemian
anti-trinitarian Heretics
a false Christ who was made equal with
the father didn't cancel any sin at the
cross
is not ruling and reigning as a priest
king right now
stick around for next week folks that's
what next week's topic of video is going
to be about
Seated on his throne over Heaven and
Earth
because Ellen claimed this here's why I
say that it's not me just talking out of
the side of my neck
this is the first Vision folks December
1844 supposedly
notice what's said here
about four months since I had a vision
of events all in the future
and I saw the time of trouble such as
never was Jesus told me
that's the word of God
Jesus told me
it was the time of Jacob's trouble and
that we should be delivered out of it by
the voice of God
just before we entered it we all
received the Seal of the Living God then
I saw the Four Angels cease to hold the
Four Winds and I saw famine pestilence
and sword Nation Rose against nation and
the whole world was in confusion
then we cried to God for deliverance day
and night till we began to hear the
bells on Jesus's garment
and I saw Jesus rise up in the holiest
and as he came out we heard the tinkling
of the Bells
and knew our high priest was coming out
then we heard the voice of God which
shook the heavens and earth and gave the
144 000 the day and hour of Jesus's
coming
then the Saints
that's them the little flock at the time
were free United and full of the glory
of God for he had turned their captivity
and I saw a flaming Cloud come where
Jesus stood and he laid off his Priestly
garment
and put on his kingly robe
took his place on the cloud which
carried him to the east where it first
appeared to the Saints on earth a small
black cloud which was the sign of the
son of man while the cloud was passing
from the holiest to the east which took
a number of days the synagogue of Satan
worshiped at the Saints feet
close quote
so she had a vision where Jesus told her
the day and the hour of his coming
false they were the 144 000 false Jesus
is wearing levitical priesthood garments
in heaven balls Jesus is yet to take the
role of a king false
while they can tell us they believe
Jesus is after the order of Melchizedek
they don't actually understand what that
entails and this proves it
levitical garments folks were unique to
the Levites even if we wanted to Grant
the SDA is one of their favorite
you know their Roy gain it was only a
vision she wasn't saying he's actually
wearing those it just represents a
function
you still have them representing a
function which claims here to see a true
change of Jesus's function just like
they claimed happened in 1844. where
he'll take off the Priestly garment AKA
he'll cease functioning as a mediator
and he puts on the kingly he assumes the
function now of a king she did not
understand that Melchizedek unlike the
Levites was both a high priest and a
king
he was a priest king Hebrews 7 1. so
Jesus functions as a high priest king
right now he's already ruling and
reigning as all of his enemies are being
made his footstool and he will forever
be in that role
Bridging the Gap between God and man as
the God man himself or ever which is
what he is doing currently he will never
cease from them he will reign forever as
they priest came
there's another like a whole host of
problems beyond that regarding the
Adventist Jesus but all of that to say
Mr Priebe I don't think that's all worth
dying for
I don't think that's worth dying for
he continues I'm gonna go right up these
trees we're going to take a look at them
and see what we can find we're going to
start with a tree that is on the left
hand side of your paper and we're going
to identify as we go this gospel says
that sin and the problem with us is we
are sinners
the question is why how did we get that
way what is this sin problem that we
have
and this gospel says sin is not what you
say or do or think
sin is what Adam did and said and
thought as well as Eve in other words
when Adam and Eve sinned they not only
turned this world upside down they
turned our Natures inside out so that
the nature that God gave us which was
loving and kind and generous and
faithful and obedient now became jealous
and proud and arrogant and disobedient
and we fight against those Natures every
day of Our Lives so these Natures that
we receive from Adam and Eve this this
gospel says that is our sin all you have
to do to become a sinner in the sight of
God is to get yourself born and draw
your first breath sin is the nature that
you inherited at your birth now as we go
through this little study this morning
I'm going to be sharing little snippet
statements from various individuals and
I want you to remember one thing as we
go through these little statements every
statement that I will read on both sides
of these gospel trees is from a
Seventh-Day Adventist
it may be a teacher a pastor a layperson
but all of the statements are from
Seventh-Day Adventists that I'm going to
share with you here's the first one
okay
that's why I also called it a quasi-sda
gospel because the statements that he's
reading from tonight folks are from
Seventh amethyst all of them so remember
that but
this is supposed to be the Christian
gospel right off the bat he says
Christians do not believe sin is what
you say do or think Richard
is that true
absolutely not
um you know sin is multi-dimensional and
first of all I would point out that the
Greek word used in the New Testament for
sin
does include more than just action
um the idea behind it is of missing the
Mark if you think of um like an arrow
shooting at the Target and missing the
mark That's what is being conveyed
when the word sin is used
and however as we know sin does include
more than that
from from that missing the mark proceeds
all these actual Corruptions all these
instances where we fall short where we
don't love God with all our heart soul
and mind and we don't love our neighbor
as ourself
and so that's just patently false that
it's only our nature
you know
um of course
you know Christians would would believe
more than that
as
go ahead anything else oh I mean it's I
just didn't want to cut you off if
you're good if you don't have anything
else
I mean it's it's evident that we believe
more than that I mean read
s and confessions I mean read
expositions of the law written by
Christians
um and the great detail that these
theologians these great men that the
Lord has given the church over the ages
have given
of all the different ways we can sin
against God I mean that's a total
misrepresentation to say it's only
nature now he would he would he's would
argue that sin doesn't have that
dimension of nature that it's only
behaviors
and that's where he would get it wrong
but it's a total straw man to say that
Christians don't believe that actions
thoughts you know words Deeds Etc are
sin yeah so he badly badly badly engages
in the fallacy of conflation
he conflates Original Sin
the teaching and Doctrine around
headship man being a fallen creature
dead in sins and trespasses Ephesians 2
which is regarding man's sinful
condition with what sin is in general
so folks we have an article on this on
our website what is sin
please come in and check this out again
it's all hyperlinked
I mean we go into this in great detail
because this is one of the major
problems
that the Adventist Church deals with
which is their very truncated view of
sin but as you can see we get into and
this isn't answering adventism's unique
opinion by the way
um we get into a variety of categories
so to say that it's not Behavioral or
that Christians don't believe it's
behavioral and what he's presenting is
supposed to be the Christian Gospel
um is not uh not entirely accurate
but Richard
the reason it's not an accurate
representation
is because of what I would say
Romans 5 12-21 even if he wants to argue
it's only Behavioral
it's not conditional
because he kind of says this in in like
a little bit of like a balking and
scoffing sort of way of like they
believe this and and that's in error
he said when Adam and Eve sinned they
turned our natures inside out
yes Mr priest that's what being dead and
sins and trespasses
a CH a child of Wrath by nature is
but the SDA system does not have a
category for this
the SDA Church
is stuck in strictly a physical frame of
reference
which also explains why they don't
properly understand the new birth and
being born again
and all that ultimately stems from them
not understanding Union with Christ
That's What It ultimately comes down to
is not understanding Union with Christ
because that involves being made a new
creature in Christ that's not just
behavior modification like they like to
say
um there's something a lot bigger going
on there all right so he said all the
statements moving forward are from
Seventh-Day Adventists remember that
a baby is born a sinner before it has
ever committed one sinful Act
that's this statement right here a baby
is born a sinner before it has ever
committed one sinful act now what is the
implication of that here's another
statement this sinful State means that
if a baby dies a few hours after birth
he or she is subject to the second death
even though he or she has never broken
any commandment
that is what sin as nature is teaching
that every baby born is born under
condemnation every baby born and of
course the solution for that in many
churches is infant baptism
because of this very serious problem
that we are born as Sinners because Adam
sins so that's the bottom line of this
gospel this understanding
okay
he says this so assuredly
babies who die hours after death
because of a sinful nature if they have
a sinful nature they'll be subject to
the second death which he means
essentially damnation
as if it's just a guarantee
but he conveniently ignores that God has
the same freedom to save infants that he
does adults
he's not limited by creatures meaning
like level of development
so his anthropocentric way of thinking
is clouding his his judgment here
but again their system has no category
for such a thing
because of that they say the eight they
hold to the whole age of accountability
that
isn't found in scripture anywhere to try
and give a pass to all like 10 to 11 and
under year olds
by rejecting this to be consistent he
also has to reject Jesus the second Adam
as the new federal head if you're going
to balk and scoff at the idea of uh
representation
headship the idea of yeah a baby is is
born a human therefore like all Humanity
they have a federal head he's
essentially just getting at the
augustinian pelagian controversy here
and then saying this is the gospel which
we'll get into that in a little bit a
little bit more later but
that's the consistent ends of what he's
essentially rejecting is if you reject
all Humanity having a federal head then
you then have to reject Jesus being the
new federal head which I guess to be
consistent
um that would make sense for the last
generation theology types
um but it again it does not align with
the Apostle Paul in Romans 5.
when Adam sinned all sinned
therefore as one trespass led to
condemnation for all men
so one act of righteousness leads to
justification and life for all men the
all there is referring back to the all
that it says are in Jesus so all that
are in Adam receive condemnation all
that are in Jesus receive eternal life
Redemption all the benefits of being
united to Christ as your new federal
head Etc
I mean heck he says for us by one man's
Disobedience the many were made sinners
I mean Romans 5 19 is just
but then he mentioned infant baptism
Richard
an original sin
before we get to that I guess anything
that you have to say period but then I
want to ask you why do we as Protestants
affirm infant baptism
um because what he presented is more of
like a Roman Catholic
or an Eastern understanding of why they
baptize infants
um
tell us why we believe in infant baptism
over and against that claim but then
anything else you want to add on that
well yeah he assumes the baptismal
regeneration position that Protestants
or whoever for that matter I mean to be
honest some Churches do hold that
position as you mentioned
but he assumes that everyone baptizes an
infant in order to wash away this guilt
of original sin
and um he may be oblivious I know I was
until I studied into the issue of the
covenantal perspective that we find in
the scripture that in every Covenant God
has included not only Believers but
their children
and and the newer and better Covenant we
hold that that pattern has not ceased I
mean for that matter it says explicitly
in Acts 2 39 that the promise is to you
and to your children
and so
us Protestants who are Pato baptistic
that just means an infant that word Pato
we hold that because God has always
included Believers in their children in
his covenants we don't see that as
changing under the new and better
Covenant and so
infants ought to receive that Covenant
sign of entry into that Covenant
not to wash away some some guilt but to
show that God includes them go look up
First Corinthians 7 14 for example and
what it says about the children of
Believers being holy it's the same Greek
word used for Saint there
and
you know you the viewers May
not have studied this issue out they may
disagree with what I'm saying and what
we believe is a
you know presbyterian-oriented guys but
the reality is
we're not baptizing an infant to wash
away that guilt we're baptizing an
infant because of God's promise
that when that infant comes to faith in
Christ everything signified in that
baptism is freely theirs yeah
yeah so all that not to Sidetrack
tonight into baptism but really just to
say that um
that's that's not necessarily why
Protestants hold to infant baptism Mr
privy
um there are some people uh that that
would
um but all that to say that it's just
kind of an insight into where we're
headed in the sort of understanding of
these things his whole issue is really
so far stemming from a faulty view of
Covenant and headship
because that's exactly why we baptize
infants
already he's strong man he
um you know and saying you know implying
at least that everyone who does infant
baptism is doing it for this reason
otherwise if the baby dies the baby is
condemned of course not realizing that
you know we believe in such a thing as
elect infants
yeah
the same freedom to save infants that he
does adults right God God is not
dependent upon somebody's age as to who
he can save however in the Adventist
system of hyper Free Will I would call
it you know obviously the child can't
hear all these things they must do
things that he's going to talk about in
a little bit and so because they can't
do that if they were guilty you know how
could they be saved and so his solution
is to suggest that they're not guilty
that there's some sort of um
intermediate State between
Sinner and
righteous
they're going to become a sinner
inevitably but they're not right now it
just it doesn't make any sense uh one
more thing I wanted to point out is It
ultimately gets back to the question of
which comes first
do human beings do we as human beings
sin
because we are sinners or are we Sinners
because we have sinned
and in previous system clearly his
thinking is
you're not a sinner until you
make that decision to commit that for
sin and if that's the case I would just
ask why is sin Universal if it's just a
fallen nature that we're born with just
a tendency to sin how come nobody has
ever escaped that
how come it inevitably brings us all
into sin in the need of salvation
yeah that's a good point
um and I don't want to jump the gun
folks because we're gonna I want to get
going here because we are going to have
a lot of stuff to to look at tonight and
it will pick up the pace he's starting a
little bit slow here but I just want to
highlight
we haven't heard the gospel yet I know
we're talking about original sin and
infant baptism Etc that's not really
what's in Focus tonight we're kind of
just commenting on some of the things
he's saying here in passing but I want
people to to focus in on that this is
the gospel
we're told this is the mainstream
Christian Gospel so just remember that
as we're moving forward
whoops and if this that's true then the
next point is obviously true that Jesus
Christ when he comes down to this world
if he is to be my savior he cannot be a
sinner
and so therefore if sin is the nature
that I am born with then without even
opening the Bible at all to read one
Bible text it is absolutely essential
that Christ not have our nature
so Christ has to have Adam's unfallen
nature there is no possibility of any
other option Christ must have an
unfallen nature so those are the first
two points of this gospel and because
that is so crucial to this gospel I want
to make sure we understand it so I'm
going to go back down to that first
Point again sin is nature and look at it
carefully here's a baby born into this
world born under condemnation born lost
that baby growing up accepts Jesus
Christ as his or her savior at that
point the Fallen nature does not
disappear
it comes under the control of the Holy
Spirit we call it the new birth so that
means that that Fallen nature is just as
much sin after the New Birth as it was
before the New Birth it is sinning still
by Nature
so after the New Birth the difference is
that we are forgiven for that nature
so the nature is still sin but we have
forgiveness for it and that's all well
and good but now we come to a point
called the close of human probation
and at the close of human probation
there is no evidence in scripture or in
any inspiration that we are going to
lose our fallen Natures at that point
in fact the only time we'll ever lose
that Fallen nature that we were born
with is when Jesus comes in the Clouds
Of Heaven
Richard
thoughts on that
well he said there's no evidence that
we're going to lose our fallen nature at
this close of probation I would just say
that you know he's obviously assuming
Adventist great controversy theology
into things there's no evidence in the
scripture of this Adventist concept of
the close of probation where if you
don't have
your whole act together and do all these
things you're supposed to do that now
it's too late for you I mean scripture
is clear
that Christ always lives to make
intercession for us
and so this whole thing is obviously
assuming great controversy Ellen White
teaching into the Bible
yeah 100 well that's why I was saying
it's a quasi-like SDA Christian hybrid
thing because even the fact that he's
mentioning uh the close of human
probation he's talking about this tree
that's supposed to be the mainstream
Christian Gospel but then he's importing
into it because remember he's he's
trying to say that Adventists have been
influenced by this so there's still
elements of adventism that are ported in
and then they're trying to understand
those things in this case the close of
human probation through this other
gospel and that's what he's going to
call Patchwork theology later but I want
to highlight and I'm going to be saying
this a lot tonight folks we still
haven't heard the gospel
what we've heard what's going to develop
into comparing systematic theology
but we haven't heard the gospel yet
interesting
this what he said here is insight into
the weak understanding of glorification
in their theology that's the key issue
did you notice he said there's no
evidence in scripture or in any
inspiration
meaning scripture and Ellen White I just
thought that was interesting like when I
heard that I played that back I probably
heard that now like 10 times I'm like
did I hear that correctly
says there's no evidence in scripture or
in any inspiration
but he's essentially folks regurgitating
about Ellen White said how do we know
that
well
it's of course
Sons and Daughters January 3rd so this
is a book that's a 365 type thing you
have something for each day this is
January 3rd from that book page nine
quote we're not to settle down expecting
that a change of character will come to
us by some miraculous work when Jesus
shall appear in the Clouds Of Heaven
with power and great Glory
know my young friends we're judgment
bound and probation is granted to us
here in this life in order that we may
form characters for future Immortal Life
hello squat
so despite her false View
of Resurrection which is really more
like cloning as we'll see in a moment
we've looked at before she's clearly
says no changing character is going to
happen at Christ's return
one must get to a perfected character
right now
that's what probation's for
nothing will change in the human will
according to her
so he's right that's why Adventist
theology purports that with the help of
the Holy Spirit you can essentially get
to a glorified State now through mere
behavior modification
all that's lacking at that point is
access to the Tree of Life
and the body of new particles that Ellen
claimed God would make and pour it into
that new body a person's character from
his memory
but that misses a key aspect of
glorification
look how the Westminster Confession
describes this
uh we could look at others it's not like
this is
whole cloth unique to the Westminster
but notice what it says
the bodies of men after death return to
dust and see corruption
but their souls which neither die nor
sleep
having an immortal sustenance
immediately returned to God who gave
them
The Souls of the righteous being then
made perfect in Holiness are received
into the highest Heavens where they
behold the face of God in light and
Glory waiting for the full Redemption of
their bodies
and The Souls of the wicked are cast
into hell where they remain in torments
and utter Darkness reserved to the
Judgment of the great day
besides these two places for Souls
separated from their bodies the
scripture knoweth none
so the key being the spirits of the
righteous made perfect where are they
pointing to Hebrews or where are they
pointing to for this Hebrews chapter 12.
what does it say Hebrews 12 18-24
.
for you've not come to what may be
touched
a blazing fire and darkness and Gloom
and a tempest and the sound of a trumpet
a voice whose words made the hears beg
that no further message be spoken to
them
for they could not endure the order that
was given if even a beast touches the
mountain it shall be stoned indeed so
terrifying was the sight that Moses said
I tremble with fear
but you following with the the compare
and contrast throughout the whole book
but you the New Covenant believer have
come to the Mount Zion and the City of
the Living God the heavenly Jerusalem
and to innumerable angels in Festival
Gathering and to the assembly of the
firstborn who are enrolled in heaven and
to God the judge of all and to the
spirits of the righteous made perfect
and to Jesus the mediator of a new
covenant
and of the sprinkled blood that speaks a
better word than the blood of Abel so
this is doing a compare and contrast
between the New Covenant believer and
the old Mosaic Covenant believer and it
uses Mount Zion Mount Sinai in contrast
to Mount Zion to show why Mount Zion is
a better Mountain why Jesus is a better
Moses Etc that's the sort of thing
that's going on here now ironically
enough
Ellen White taught that the spirit of a
person was their character
now like I said we've looked at this
before on the channel
regarding their teaching on Resurrection
this is the SDA Bible commentary by way
of Ellen White
quote our personal identity is preserved
in the resurrection though not the same
particles of matter or material
substance as went into the grave it is
not the self-same body
the wondrous works of God are a mystery
to man The Spirit the character of man
is returned to God there to be preserved
in the resurrection every man will have
his own character
again in Last Day Events page 295.
quote if you would be a saint in heaven
you must first be a saint on Earth
the traits of character you cherish in
life will not be changed by death or by
the resurrection
you will come up from the grave with the
same disposition you manifested in your
home and in society Jesus does not
change the character at his coming
the work of transformation must be done
now
again probation
our daily lives are determining our
destiny defects of character must be
repented of and overcome through the
grace of Christ and asymmetrical
character must be formed talking about a
symmetrical character to Christ
while in this probationary state that we
may be fitted for the Mansions Above
so Richie
if you plug that definition into what
the author of Hebrews tells us
New Covenant Believers unlike the Saints
of old come to a better Mount Mountain
Zion over and against Sinai he's
sticking with the entire theme he's he's
been talking about up to this point all
the way all the ways that the New
Covenant is better but he tells us that
Believers can approach this better
Mountain where there's a festival
Gathering of Angels the Saints of old
and the spirits of the righteous made
perfect
all of these are obviously animated
creatures
sentient they're aware Etc
a personality or character of a person
is not animate
but let's grant them their definition of
spirit being a person's character
if we plug that into Hebrews 12
there's a change of character happening
the characters make the characters made
perfect
so even with their faulty definition you
still have a changing character
happening at a period outside of the
supposed probation window
and the whole thing is a failure to
understand that God works in process you
know if we consider the whole of
scripture God works through processes
over and over again typically gradually
I mean we see creation done over you
know six days obviously God could have
done it in a second but he did it over
six days we see
a time period elapsed between When sin
enters and when the Savior comes we see
that scripture God gave it gradually
over a period of roughly 1500 years and
so
God's pattern is to work gradually in
these things and that's what he does
with us and so we come to Christ we are
Justified sins penalty is removed we
also receive sanctification at that
moment being set apart to God which is
what it means in its most basic sense
but then a process begins of growing in
Christ which continues through our life
and at the end of our life
or you know if the Lord came back first
there's that glorification that happens
where we enter into the state of glory
and so there's a process but what
Adventist theology does is it short
circuits the process it puts
glorification
Here and Now into sanctification I mean
get a Bible definition of what it means
to be glorified for example Romans 3 the
Apostle Paul tells us that we have all
sinned and fallen short of the glory of
God
sin is the opposite of the glory of God
I.E glorification and so
when we're no longer sinning is when we
shall have that Glory well Adventists
themselves will say glorification
happens at the second coming or in the
Life to Come
but then they will import what Biblical
glorification would be the absence of
sin into the present and again you know
so many failures to make distinctions
you know conflating obviously they
conflate justification and
sanctification as we'll see him do more
as we go on but also conflating
glorification and sanctification as well
yeah totally well and he said there's no
biblical evidence of the character you
know being changed or anything no Dennis
you're wrong
by the way that your prophetess defines
Spirit as character that would mean the
author of Hebrews is saying the
character of the righteous is made
perfect upon death because it's talking
in the present tense it's not oh let us
because I've heard Adams try and say oh
no that's that Hebrews 12 was talking
about this long thing off in the future
about that's the people who have made it
they they are arrived at Perfection and
then they were they were made righteous
here and then arrived and got there to
the the city because we're not there yet
that type sort of stuff you know despite
the whole thing
right and despite the fact that Paul
says we're by being united to Christ
you're presently seated with him in the
heavenlies all these now and not yet
type um things that are presented but
um to answer that Dennis yes both your
inspired prophetess and scripture say
such so to say that there's nothing in
scripture about that is just um kind of
odd but he continues so that means we
are still sinning by Nature after the
close of probation
and that means we still need forgiveness
after the close of probation which means
Jesus cannot step out of the most holy
place of the Heavenly sanctuary
which means there must be forgiveness
for ongoing sin right up until the
second coming of Christ
so that is what this teaching says we
sin from the moment of our birth to the
moment of our death or until Jesus comes
and we need forgiveness for constant sin
all the way to the second coming sin is
as constant as breathing
all right to the second Point Jesus
Christ
you know it really isn't about his
nature
it's about how he was tempted
Adam and Eve in the garden
could Satan make life miserable for Adam
and Eve by harassing them around the
garden day after day
the rules are very strict weren't they
one tree one tree not only in the garden
but in the whole world
at which they could be tempted would you
like that arrangement
one tree of Temptation you'd have to go
out there to find temptation
well
after Adam and Eve sinned did The Rules
of Engagement change
where could Satan now tempt Adam and Eve
anywhere anytime out there somewhere
do you have to go over there to find
temptation or do you have to wake up in
the morning
go to sleep at night and he's there
pulling at you through your nature
all right so the rules today are is
Satan has access to you constantly
through your own nature through the
nature that you have within you
and so the real question comes down to
this how was Christ tempted like Adam
or like us that's the issue of the
second point and you know this gospel
says
not like us like Adam in fact I've heard
one explanation that says Christ was
tempted three times in his experience he
was tempted in the wilderness he was
tempted In The Garden of Gethsemane he
was tempted at the cross of Calvary and
the unique thing about all those three
is he went over there to find temptation
not back in Nazareth but he went out
there and there he was tempted in the
wilderness in the garden at the cross
so Christ was tempted like Adam was
tempted over there outside of himself
not tempted to be angry not tempted
doing patience or Pride or selfishness
or overeating or all of The Temptations
that we have but just on the great
issues would he carry out his mission as
the Messiah would he be obedient to his
heavenly father in dying for the sins of
mankind
so the bottom line of the second point
is Christ was not tempted in the same
areas that we are tempted he was not
tempted from within that would make him
a sinner
he was tempted only from without as Adam
was tempted so those are the first two
points in this gospel now we come to
where the rubber begins to hit the road
justification salvation and you notice
that it says justification only not
sanctification here's the reason for it
I'll share it from a statement
justification
is one hundred percent Christ's work
sanctification is a work done by us
aided by the indwelling Christ
well my friends is a work done by us
worth anything for salvation
zero
which means that if justification is 100
his work and sanctification is a work
done by us that sanctification cannot be
part of the saving equation of the way
we are saved now what does that mean in
Practical terms
let's say that you've been a faithful
Sabbath keeper for a year or so
but you've decided that in these hard
Economic Times you really can't feed
your family clothed your family without
opening your business on Sabbath and so
you decide reluctantly to go against the
convictions of your heart and open your
business on Sabbath and keep it open
regularly does that in any way
jeopardize your salvation
now that would be a sanctification issue
wouldn't it the keeping of The
Seventh-Day Sabbath on a regular basis
and sanctification according to this
gospel is not part of the Gospel it's a
result of the Gospel it happens after
you're saved you're saved and then the
sanctification process takes over and it
isn't crucial to Salvation
so let me read you a little statement by
somebody who has kind of thought about
this subject a little bit since right
behavior is never the ground of our
acceptance with God is that correct that
is correct since right behavior is never
the ground of our acceptance with God
wrong Behavior cannot keep a person out
of heaven
follow that little bit of logic
since right Behavior won't get you in
wrong Behavior won't keep you out one is
not lost by not keeping the Sabbath or
giving up the Sabbath one is saved
because one chooses to enter into a
saving relationship with Jesus the only
way to lose that salvation is if a
person chooses to reject that saving
relationship
see this is a very simple gospel
there is one way into salvation except
Jesus Christ as your savior
once you have done that there is only
one way out of Salvation to lose your
salvation and that is to turn your back
on Jesus Christ and say I don't want you
in my life anymore I'm going my own way
and yes you can lose your salvation
experience with Jesus Christ by doing
that but anything in between that
you're still saved Sabbath breaking
sanctification issue you're still saved
as long as you are Justified as long as
you are forgiven you are still saved
withholding of tithes you're still saved
and we could go down the whole list
including adultery and you're still
saved because all sanctification issues
are non-salvation issues and the only
way to lose your salvation is to reject
justification
as forgiveness
and then you can lose your salvation so
that becomes the critical issue of this
gospel justification alone is the issue
in Salvation
okay so I know that was a lot that were
probably the longest one out of all of
them but I wanted to I wanted to catch
all that he just assumes their doctrine
of probation which I get it he said at
the at the beginning it's a compare and
contrast not a Bible study but there's
an agreed upon belief between these two
supposed gospels because notice he's
trying to talk about what's been this is
the sort of thing these other Adventist
pastors are saying they've taken this
Christian Gospel and tried to advertise
it if you will
um
but again this is all through the great
controversy theme
and furthermore the more important part
and as it goes along further folks I'm
going to keep asking this we haven't
heard the gospel yet
Richard is probation a part of the
Gospel
absolutely not I mean
probation is what happened back clear
back in the garden I mean Adam was given
a law and he failed to keep that law and
uh you know again we talked about
representation a little bit earlier
you know once once he failed it's done
and so once we get past that point the
gospel enters in Grace enters in
you know as I listen to
um to that clip it was almost God
excruciating you know that he's
describing it's clear you know the that
there's this concept of salvation that
God is sort of using it as some sort of
a punitive Club if you don't do
everything right I'm yanking it out from
under you and of course he mentioned you
know big sins you know like committing
adultery and such but what about all the
numerous little sins that we all
struggle with every day what about
the greatest commandment the fact that
we don't love God with all our heart
soul and strength every minute and don't
love our neighbor as ourself every
minute
is our thing is our Salvation being
yanked because of that in his mind
that'd be my question
yeah and that's exactly it is this again
it goes back to this very truncated view
of sin because when you take umbrage
with them on stuff like he just said
they're going to say well then they're
going to jump to this other extreme oh
so you're saying people can just live
however they want adultery doesn't
matter it's like whoa buddy relax that's
not what's being said at all it's
because you have this very narrow small
honed in sort of view of sin First John
3 it's transgressional law therefore the
letter of the Ten Commandments
when it's not even saying Mr privy if
you have an impure thought
but then they'll get into stuff like
well that wasn't volitional that wasn't
by choice or you know these sorts of
things and it's like well guy you're
missing it you're missing it they don't
have a concept of both Christ passive
and active obedience which is what is is
required it's what Christ passively did
as the the free will the ultimate Free
Will offering is the suffering servant
um over and against what he did not do
and abstained from doing constantly
actively Moment by moment second by
second that's the standard sir it's not
just oh well today did I bow down to a
statue did I worship any other false
gods did you put anything in your life
that day ahead of God then it was an
idol
it's not just bowing down to statues or
these very like
caricatured ways that they'll often
present you know what sin is and then so
when you disagree they think you're
saying these like oh it's so easy to do
just go to church on Saturday don't tell
any lies don't commit adultery don't bow
down to a statue don't worship a false
god by you know accept Jesus the the
true God and obey your parents and
that's really all it's just like and
then when you disagree with them it's
like oh so you're saying you can do you
can break those things well that you're
you're missing the whole point it's way
deeper than that my man
you're you're missing the full scope of
of what the standard actually is it's
not just the letter of the Ten
Commandments but really this all stems
from him not having an uh understanding
or concept of Union with Christ
Union with with Christ makes no sense in
a probationary model
because God does not disown children
that he adopts
and adoption is one of the many many
benefits that one receives by being in
Christ
and again like I said earlier we've
heard nothing really so far about the
gospel remember he said he's comparing
two gospels with an adventism
he's really comparing two false gospels
but then he said sin is as constant as
breathing so that's a perfect example of
what I was just saying is like
well it's it's a very it's a very
caricatured understanding of what's
being said by original sin Dennis
it doesn't mean that literally every
single second a person's either
committing a lie committing adultery
that's not what people are saying that
and again this gets back to the the
faulty understanding of man's actual
disposition that there's an actual issue
by nature and why the born-again
experience is so much more than just ah
it's Paul using like Poetic you know or
metaphorical language to sort of paint
this sort of image in your mind
no there's actually something going on
in in the nature or the being of the the
person so I thought that was interesting
but did you notice how man centered
this supposed gospel is
and that's what he's painting
Christianity as he calls this the
mainstream Christian Gospel but it's
completely void of the full picture of
what the Bible says regarding the
morning and experience
I mentioned this earlier being made a
new creature in Christ
which again is a term of of Union with
Christ
and the their problem being this very
narrow-sided low view of sin uh notice
he only listed like you mentioned you
caught that as well he only listed
violations of the letter of the Ten
Commandments
yet the standard is loving God and
neighbor perfectly in thought word deed
and motive 24 7.
but with a very narrow view of sin it's
easy to Eclipse God's holiness
of which I heard nothing of in all of
that I heard nothing about the Holiness
of God
even when he's going on about babies
being born fallen in Adam
he didn't mention anything about the
Holiness of God
exactly and you know
again
they have no concept of what it means to
be dead in sin I listen to this guy I've
listened to the majority of his messages
and I don't think I've ever heard him
reference Ephesians chapter 2.
and what it says about
you were dead in trespasses and sins but
God made you alive in Christ
we were by Nature children of Wrath
Ephesians 2 3.
and yet he's arguing
you know that Christ could have
Christ was essentially like us is
at the core of his message okay
but we're by Nature children of Wrath
what does it mean by Nature
if Christ not our nature it it just
doesn't work it doesn't work well like
you mentioned that
there's a term there of uh referring to
Union with Christ
We Were Made Alive together with him in
him we were made alive together so yeah
it really all stems from a faulty
understanding of Union with Christ but
really thus far he hasn't gotten to the
Adventist gospel which will be the the
more interesting aspect here I'm just
going to continue harping on this we
haven't heard the gospel yet so I'm
waiting Dennis for your presentation of
of
the gospel and not
Systematic Theology and points of of
that
all right as we begin to travel up the
tree we come to the last point of this
gospel if all of that is true if we are
sinning by Nature until Jesus comes
forget the talk of perfection it is not
going to happen in this life it will
wait until Jesus comes uh Perfection of
character is something that is dangerous
something that we should not be focusing
on something that is not relevant to us
today
all right now this gospel that I've been
describing is the Orthodox mainstream
Gospel of the Christian churches today
it has been for centuries this is
mainstream Orthodox Christianity if
you've ever watched those great scenes
in the great Sports Arenas where an
evangelist of renown gives a call to to
accept Jesus Christ as Savior and
hundreds hundreds stream up to the front
and kneel before the throat before the
altar
this is the gospel they're responding to
this is the gospel of Christianity now
this gospel has been impinging on The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church for the
past 30 to 40 years and so there are
fruits that are being born within the
Seventh-day Adventist Church
foreign
so
how would you Richard
how would you rate his presentation so
far of the Orthodox
mainstream gospel
well
he said nothing of what we would say as
mainstream Orthodox Christians that the
gospel is I've heard nothing about Jesus
Christ death and Resurrection I have
heard nothing about him
living for us paying for our sins dying
in our place or any of that that you
know we would describe as being part of
the Gospel we've just heard this
systematic on on sin and
nature and so forth but you know we've
heard nothing of how we would biblically
Define the gospel as Christians
yeah I heard nothing about the person
and work of Christ which is the good
news yeah
uh he equates easy believism with the
gospel so he points to like the Billy
Graham revivals you know like like 20th
century American revivalism that's
mainstream Christianity that's the
mainstream gospel this sort of like get
your ticket punched get out of hell free
card if you say a prayer type idea
um
and he he proves in in that as well
that when Adventists hear the real
gospel this is why they're flabbergasted
because what he thinks is mainstream
Christianity is just Western 20th
century novelty that he says
um
has has influenced adventism and has
caused a rift that's why I called this
an SDA quasi-christian hybrid gospel
this is what I get sdas constantly
telling me that I believe
when what this guy presented tonight is
two false gospels or he's going to get
into the second one here
by comparing and contrasting them and
the one that's supposed to be the
Christian Gospel is a caricature
now he's going to talk about the fruits
of this supposed gospel on SDA theology
so the tree trunk is supposed to be the
gospel and then the branches are
supposed to be the fruit so this is now
the fruit of this mainstream Orthodox
Christian Gospel on Seventh-Day
adventism in some pockets of adventism
the judgment
that we believe began in 1844.
judgment why do we need a judgment
judgment that's opposite to the gospel
the gospel is love and forgiveness and
mercy judgment is arbitrary and harsh
and negative if you've accepted Jesus
you're saved
and this judgment issue is very simple
uh in this gospel you don't need a
judgment all you need is a good
recording Angel secretary
who writes in the record books of Heaven
saved January 25 1994 checks down the
record book still accepts Jesus still
saved
that's the only issue have you accepted
Jesus and do you still accept Jesus what
do you need a judgment for
are you going to judge Sabbath keeping
no are you going to judge tithe
returning no those are sanctification
issues and that's why in many Minds the
justification the the Judgment that
began in 1844 is not only irrelevant
but negative to the gospel contradicts
the gospel destroys the gospel makes
light of the Cross of Calvary and so
there has been much opposition to this
judgment beginning in 1844.
okay so again
this is supposed to be the Orthodox
mainstream Christian gospel still
nothing about the person and work of
Christ gives us a lot of systematic
theology but it isn't the gospel
but did you notice he equivocates
between even though he's misrepresenting
and so well he's he's trying to say this
is the way that some Adventists have
tried to take this American or Christian
mainstream gospel and have tried to
bring it into adventism and do like a
hybrid sort of thing but did you notice
that he equivocates between judgment
entirely and the investigative judgment
he said in this gospel which this is
supposed to be the mainstream Christian
Gospel you don't need a judgment
except you know the Apostles Creed I
mean seriously it's like the
six-year-olds getting catechized at my
church can tell you this it's like base
level Christianity
it's just silly to say that Christians
don't believe in any kind of judgment
that's negative that's harsh that's
well right I mean
everyone has you know every Orthodox
Christian
confesses the doctrine in the Apostles
Creed you know he
he sits at the right hand of God the
Father Almighty and from there he shall
come to judge the living and the dead
you know that's a universal belief and
yet the investigative judgment is
entirely a unique novelty only found in
adventism
and yet we're to believe that if we
reject this 19th century novelty that we
don't believe there's any kind of a
judgment when that's what
our forefathers in the faith have
confessed for two thousand years
just a straw Manning yeah it's just like
what are you talking about the the
mainstream Christian Gospel which again
we we haven't heard anything about the
personal work of Christ but he's what he
means when he says gospel is the whole
system
of theology that's that's what they
think the gospel is because that's how
it is in adventism it's this big
convoluted system of theology so that's
what he's trying to say is that
mainstream Christians don't even have a
concept of judgment it's like Dennis
have you even read I mean
it's like the most foremost Christian
you know summation document in the world
it like transcends continent it's just
like it's one of the oldest Christian
documents it's like foundational base
level Christianity
but again let's reference the
Westminster Confession just because
again we could refer to a number of them
just to
explore this supposed point
what does it say of the last judgment
is it anything like like Dennis claims
you don't need a judgment the mainstream
Christian Gospel their theology they
don't have a gen
quote
God hath appointed today wherein he will
judge the world in righteousness by
Jesus Christ to whom all power and
judgment is given of the father in which
day not only the apostate angels will be
judged but likewise all persons
but likewise
all persons
that have lived upon the Earth shall
appear before the tribunal of Christ to
give an account of their thoughts words
and deeds and to receive according to
what they have done in the body whether
good or evil
the end of God's appointing this day is
for the manifestation of the glory of
his Mercy in the Eternal salvation of
the elect and in his Justice in the
damnation of the reprobate who are
wicked and disobedient for then shall
the righteous go into everlasting life
and receive that fullness of joy and
refreshing which shall come from the
presence of the Lord but the wicked who
know not God and not obey the Gospel of
Jesus Christ
shall be cast into Eternal torments and
punished with Everlasting destruction
from the presence of the Lord and from
the glory of his power
so this was just one example of many he
talks as though Christians don't believe
in any sort of judgment
I've often heard them say that
if you don't understand them like it it
they don't understand that if the
investigative judgment isn't true
there's no need for a judgment like he
said they think it's because because God
needs to vindicate his character
which becomes a again man-centered
thinking he's beholden to the creation
ultimately
what we read in the confession is
god-centered it's not about God
vindicating his character
that was done at the cross
not just wearing a toning sacrifice took
place by the way
God's judgment is about demonstrating
his character not about vindicating it
it's about God
Jesus Christ is going to execute this
judgment as king of kings and Lord of
lords having all authority to throw the
wicked out of his kingdom
and notice
who does the confession properly
recognize that's done to
those that do not obey the gospel
so not disparaging obedience either
the other straw man we always hear
thoughts on that Richard before I
continue well just to clarify the
confession didn't just pull that out of
thin error that's a direct quote from
second Thessalonians 1 that says when
the Lord Jesus returns in flaming fire
taking Vengeance on those who do not
know God and do not obey the gospel
and so that's you know that's totally a
quote straight out of the Bible that
it's those who do not obey the gospel
that are going to be sentenced to
Eternal destruction as it says in the
passage
and so
what's that
no go ahead
oh and uh I lost my thought there sorry
no I'm sorry I was just gonna say that
and that's why understanding the law
gospel distinction is so important
exactly but you know again there's all
these conflations in adventism and as I
mentioned earlier conflating
justification sanctification
glorification melding everything
together also melding law and gospel
together and as I recall as I listened
to this presentation multiple times he
even
even mentioned
that God would put nothing in the Bible
if it wasn't salvational and so there's
a mentality that every single thing in
the Bible
is is
directly tied to reconciliation with God
to being saved
yeah we will see that um toward the the
end of this but folks I want you to
remember he's misrepresenting mainstream
Orthodox Christianity and saying this is
what has influenced certain Adventists
who then try and take it and filter it
through the great controversy world view
because at the end of the day that is
what binds Seventh-Day Adventists
regardless of which of these two gospels
they affirm
because Dennis still has a uniting
element with people who affirm this
there's still things that unite Dennis
to those individuals even if he's saying
that's a false gospel
there are still things that unite them
and it's because of your great
controversy worldview now he's going to
talk about
debts to Christ
also
Ellen G white and the spirit of Prophecy
issues relating to that in The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church I'm going
to share a letter that came in from
Seventh-Day Adventists to Andrews
University
how do we keep our teenagers in touch
with Christ an outstanding question how
do we keep our teenagers in touch with
Christ for starters deep six messages to
young people and all other compilations
there is not a shred of gospel in the
lot number two stop publishing steps to
Christ which is simply another Works
approach to Salvation
steps to Christ you heard me right
that's not great controversy is it
sometimes we're a little fearful that
that might be too strong for some people
but steps to Christ of all the writings
that Ellen White ever wrote isn't that
the one you feel most ease is the
easiest to give to someone else
a simple statement of how we approach
Jesus Christ as our savior how could
that be such a negative factor in their
minds to understand that I'm going to
take you back to the year 1950. when a
gentleman by the name of barnhouse who
would later come in contact with
Seventh-day Adventist leaders the editor
of Eternity magazine a very popular
Christian magazine at that time received
a copy of steps to Christ from somewhere
and he decided to review it in his
magazine let me share with you what is
what he said he said the book is false
in all its parts it Bears the mark of
the counterfeit from the first page it
contains satanic error
and I'm going to remind you again that
was steps to Christ he was reviewing
do you begin to see what the problem
really is the book steps to Christ which
describes the way of Salvation and how
we approach Christ is diametrically
opposite to the gospel that we have been
reviewing
it talks about surrender it talks about
commitment and it even gets into that
dreaded word obedience which is so
negative in this gospel's understanding
and so here was a very influential
Christian editor as I saw the book steps
to Christ as very dangerous
if you want to understand how salvation
works and apparently that's where this
letter kind of comes from that attitude
that steps to Christ is not a correct
understanding of the way of salvation
questions about Ellen White's writings
okay Richard
is steps to Christ an accurate depiction
of how one comes to Christ
no and as I was listening to that I
remember reading an article at one time
written by an Adventist and it was
actually in response I think it was in
response to
Morris vendon because Morris vendon had
a story of
well what am I going to do to get saved
and The Story Goes that he read steps to
Christ and came up with Bible study
prayer and witnessing
but
and I can't remember the name of who
wrote the article but the particular
article I read this one time pointed out
there's just dozens of things and steps
to Christ that you are supposed to do in
order to get yourself saved
in addition to you know Faith there's
all these Works listed in the book
yeah well barnhouse's statement is
exactly right that's why I said that not
because it's diametrically opposed to
your like 20th century Western American
like church that you know that period of
the church's history like caricature of
the whole
um but how's about
the plagiarism
he talks about rejecting steps to Christ
for all the wrong reasons it could be
because the theology is indeed wrong and
the writings are stolen so folks on our
website again check this out for
yourselves let's look at it you can come
under the plagiarism section here and
you can see for yourself let's look at
some of these
I mean steps to Christ is one of the
biggest and it's not even that big of a
book either so the amount of plagiarism
that there is is just crazy let's look
at it color coordinated for you to see
this is page 13 of steps to Christ The
Father loves us not because of the great
propitiation but he provided the
propitiation because he loves us Christ
was the medium through which he could
pour out his infinite love upon a Fallen
World then we have John Harris as the
great teacher
you know written
60 some years before
quote The Father loves us not in
consequence of the great propitiation
but that he provided the propitiation
because he loved us because he was bent
on obtaining a medium through which he
could pour out the ocean fullness of his
love upon us
again the same book
debster Christ next page page 14 but the
same book John Harris is the great
teacher therefore doth my father loved
me because he quotes the the scripture
there and they both quote the the
scripture
in becoming your substitute in Surety by
surrendering My Life by taking your
liabilities your transgressions I'm
endeared to my father
John Harris he quotes the same same
scripture
he gives a little rendition there in
other words my father loves you with a
love so I'm so unbounded that even loves
me the more for dying to redeem You by
sustaining your liabilities by
surrendering my life
as an equivalent for your transgressions
The Father loves me
I mean folks you can go through that
look at this
this is all steps to Christ steps to
Christ various authors I mean go this is
literally just the steps to Christ
section and it's color coordinate for
you sometimes she changes up the the
paragraph order Etc
there's no credit given to these authors
in any of these books
so Dennis
maybe that's why people also reject
steps to Christ I mean there's a variety
of reasons why people could reject it
but like you you pointed out Richard it
teaches a false way to get to Christ not
just that it teaches a false Christ
technically it's not just that it steps
to a false Christ and it's not even the
correct steps to Christ
and I don't want to I don't want to miss
either his
his implication that barnhouse was down
on obedience to God and by extension all
evangelicals I mean just Insanity I mean
you can find Barn houses materials on
YouTube and barnhouse is clearly not
opposed to obedience what he's opposed
to is obedience for reconciliation with
bingo bingo
yeah this unlawful use of the law
not understanding obedience is not a
Reconciliation tool exactly not
understanding the order that the Apostle
Paul puts it in in Ephesians 2 8-10 that
we are saved by grace through faith not
of ourselves and then following that we
are created in Christ Jesus unto good
works
notice saved occurs past tense
and once we are saved then God has
created us to do good works in Christ
Jesus which he has ordained beforehand
that we should walk in them it says and
so the people
yeah the problem is not obedience the
problem is
adventism making obedience a
Reconciliation tool making it you do
this or again you know God is going to
punitively yank it from you yeah and
we'll see some quotes later on that
because when he starts talking about
Adventist justification and
sanctification where he's like
Adventists believe in both justification
and sanctification and it's like what in
what do you mean like acting like the
mainstream Christian Gospel doesn't
believe in sanctification either so I'll
save my comments for that when we get to
that point the law The Ten Commandments
Seventh-Day Adventists say that the law
was not nailed to the cross that we that
it is for us today but yet how does that
work if we're Sinners by Nature
we're sinning constantly which means if
I read my Bible writes sin is the
transgression of what the law so means
we're breaking the law constantly how
can you have the law that you're
breaking constantly as anything
meaningful at all so questions arise
about the law and there of course is the
Sabbath right in the middle of the law
how can we make that Central if every
Sabbath keeper is a law breaker 100 of
the time
and Sabbath keeping is still impossible
if the law can't be kept
up to the top of the tree
health health issues well that is
obviously sanctification that's not
justification so if that if
sanctification is not part of the Gospel
then how can Health be that important
I'm going to read a couple of statements
on this point
God's salvation is so extravagant so
comprehensive that it can't be increased
or diminished by what we eat drink or
where did you catch that again can't be
increased or diminished by what we eat
drink or wear exercise and a good diet
contribute to a long and useful life but
they don't add to our Salvation
well this and not make such a big issue
of it why is that it may not be so
important as we thought it was after all
it's a sanctification not a
justification issue it's not a Salvation
issue
okay
so perfect demonstration how a truncated
view of sin leads to a truncated view of
the law
comments on that
well the whole thing about the law being
nailed to the cross again that is not
Orthodox Christianity show me one
historic Creed or confession from any
denomination that has the law being
nailed to the cross and as we've
discussed before this whole concept of
the law nailed to the cross is really
based on a faulty translation from
Colossians chapter 2.
what was actually nailed to the cross
was our sin debt not the law
yeah and I'm going to say my comments on
that just because he goes into that more
later and so I'll bring up some more
about that then but
yeah it's just like oh my goodness man
like don't
don't say the the mainstream Christian
because by gospel he means teaching so
he because again he uh spoiler alert
folk folks he's never going to present
the gospel
he never gets into the gospel because by
the word gospel he's using that
synonymously for system of theology or
you know a a certain teaching and he's
going to say like you mentioned earlier
that
um if God revealed it it's a Salvation
issue
um and so we'll get to that then but
it's just
show me the mainstream Christian
confession that says that you're
responding to like bad arguments from
20th century Western Christendom
um where there were people who you know
individuals saying these sorts of things
but you're not going to find a
mainstream Christian confession that's
saying the law was nailed to the cross
um it's just they love that and so if
you're if you're a former Adventist if
you're trying to engage with Adventist
please do not use that argument I'll
bring up something later in regards to
that but something else is being said
there and it actually completely
destroys adventism because it destroys
the investigative judgment in 1844 if
you understand what's actually being
said in Colossians 2. there's other
places to go to in scripture to talk
about not being under the law covenantly
all right but now he's going to go into
standards so remember we're still in the
fruit here of this mainstream Orthodox
Christian Gospel that's influenced
Seventh-day Adventist pastors
fruit now into how it's impacted the
view of standards in Seventh-Day
adventism
and then standards now I'm talking about
all the standards of The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church what we watch what we
listen to what we read our entertainment
and yes even the clothes we wear
all of the standards of the Adventist
Church obviously once again that
sanctification that's not justification
and so that can't be as important as we
thought it was another statement that I
found members give a cent to various
standards and rules as a condition of
membership in the organization we need
to keep in mind that this Ascent is not
related to their salvation only to being
a member of The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church
now watch that that little bit of logic
right there
we ask people not to we ask people if
they want to become a Seventh-Day
Adventist to lay aside tobacco and
alcohol
that is not part of the Seventh-day
Adventist way of life
now why do we do that according to this
it's because that's simply one of the
rules of the Adventist Church any group
any church has rules and if you want to
be a card-carrying member of that church
or organization you abide by those rules
but you understand that's not relevant
to Salvation the smoking and drinking
issue is a rule of the church not a
Salvation issue at all according to this
bit of logic another person said it this
way though I believe something to be
correct from a religious perspective it
is not a matter of salvation
you may have been hearing that quite a
bit in recent years this isn't a matter
of Salvation that isn't a matter of
Salvation because of this particular
emphasis anything which is not part of
justification is not a matter of
Salvation in this gospel
Okay so
Richard thoughts on that well Dennis has
spilled the beans and that is that every
little thing is an issue of Salvation in
adventism
all of the dozens and hundreds of
standards and rules
that really they come from Ellen White
because you can't find them in the
scripture are all
salvational issues they're all required
if you're gonna be saved in the end if
you're gonna make it through this close
of probation period
and again you know I'm I'm thankful for
his candidness that this is really how
it is
regardless of what the the public
relations
wing of adventism will say the reality
that
thousands and hundreds of thousands and
even millions of Adventists have lived
is everything is a salvational issue and
a failure to do something that you know
you should be doing from an Adventist
point of view
is is potentially damning you
and the thing that's so interesting
about this standards topic well there's
actually two things here it's
interesting because these Adventists
that he's pointing at it's like they're
correct in in one sense that yeah those
things are not the gospel exactly
however the they're still these people
tend to still have a great controversy
world view and so that then clouds
everything else but uh and nevertheless
he he gives a a great insight into how
this is one of those topics I haven't
done videos on it yet but we will be
um they're like the temperance doctrines
and and Christian behavior and that sort
of stuff is one of those areas man that
I think most former Adventists can
relate with because it's this false like
you mentioned all this stuff that Ellen
White put together and that is then
branded as being christ-like
so if you're outside of this sort of
like uh you know
um
manufactured perfect image of what has
like what a Christian is supposed to be
well you're in sin
and so it becomes this whole like
you know there's this uh the sort of
perfect depiction of what the Adventist
is supposed to be and that's the mark
You're supposed to be aiming for and
that stuff is salvational that's why
I'll talk with former sdas who would be
like I remember I Dale will say I
remember I used to see people with
jewelry and my thought would be well
they're definitely not saved they're not
serious they're not a serious Christian
they're wearing makeup and jewelry look
how tight those clothes are it gets into
that sort of stuff and obviously when
you say anything about this their
visceral response is typically oh so
you're saying that it doesn't they just
jump to this other extreme because
everything has to be this false binary
um I just think that's interesting
though how he he very clearly is laying
out like he was saying the clothes you
wear
your salvation hinges upon the clothes
that you wear and again like I said
they're gonna then respond and be like
so you think people can wear whatever no
you're missing the point entirely
that's not what I'm saying at all that's
what I'm saying at all if that's your
response oh man uh God bless you but
all right now he's going to transition
into what he calls his own convictions
so now he's kind of wrapping this up
before we transition into what he claims
is the real gospel where he's going to
go into a lot more detail on things
all right so what we've looked at is the
mainstream Gospel of the Christian
church and some of its impacts on
Seventh-day Adventist doctrines and
lifestyle
so here is where I'm going to share with
you my convictions
I believe that this gospel left to grow
and flourish
left to become the mainstream Gospel of
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church will
destroy seventh day adventism
we are in a life and death struggle here
this is not simply an interpretation of
Prophecy by which we can have differing
opinions and come out okay in the end
this is whether or not we are in heaven
with Jesus Christ for all eternity and
whether Seventh-Day adventism has any
future at all as God's Remnant Church
this is the heart and soul
of religion
at least he says it like it is doesn't
beat around the bush
adventism is most certainly not
Christian it is not Christianity
not that he presented Christianity
accurately there
but his point is true nonetheless
he said did you notice in there he said
you can disagree on Prophecy
he was like it's not like a prophecy
where you know you can disagree what
prophecies can you disagree with in
adventism and come out okay in the end
well history shows that
when Adventist pastors do that
particularly a certain prophecy on 1844
it goes very badly for them and so you
know this idea that you know there are
things you can disagree on in adventism
that are Adventist teaching
that's really not the case now what's
interesting is though you can't disagree
on Prophecy
you can be all over the map on the
nature of Jesus Christ or the nature
I know it's just astounding but yeah
1844 you know you got to get that right
or uh
bye bye to you
yeah
I don't know anything about his
christology I don't know what he would
say about those types but I would be
curious to know if he would have as
strong of a stance
can somebody be an Aryan heretic Dennis
in your ranks
and and then be in alignment with all
this other stuff that you've said
because he said nothing about
christology you know none of that so I'd
be curious to know if somebody who
affirms that if he would Embrace because
that would be even more telling but
I'm just thinking dude I don't know any
prophecies in adventism that you can
disagree with uh maybe all the false
prophecies
that are universally disagreed with
yeah and of course there's all the the
prophecies in Scripture that they just
ignore I think we've talked about this
before amongst ourselves that
they do a revelation seminar and really
it's certain chapters of Revelation that
they're presenting you know chapter 12
13 14 17
Etc but then skipping over the rest of
it and so again it's the selective
can and within a Canon thing maybe
there's some some things like that
you're allowed to disagree on but
historically any disagreement on these
issues has generated intense heat and
controversy within adventism itself yeah
because the whole system is basically
built on Prophecy okay now he's going to
folks they won't all be these short
little bursts like this these are just
kind of how he had stuff broken up so
now he's going to get into uh
predestination
did you notice at the bottom of the tree
there's a long word called
predestination
the reason for that is when this gospel
was first being developed in the third
and fourth centuries everyone believed
in predestination God decides who's
saved and lost you don't have a voice in
the matter and for a thousand years that
was the belief of most Christians that
we are either destined for heaven or
destined for hell with no choice in the
matter and what is very interesting is
that although predestination has been
dropped by most Christians the gospel
built on predestination is still the
mainstream gospel and if you look at it
kind of fits we're born Sinners because
of bad equipment Jesus didn't sin
because he had good equipment we're
forgiven for our bad equipment until
Jesus comes and then at Jesus coming I
guess Jesus is going to push a magic
button in our brains and we won't sin
anymore
in other words bad equipment sin good
equipment no sin end of discussion
kind of fits with predestination
how is this presentation of
predestination
well first of all
it just it jumped out at me the whole
you have no choice in the matter you
know you're either destined for life or
damnation
and what I tell people is somebody who
does believe in the doctrine people
typically think of as as predestination
that God has chosen us to be in Christ
before the foundation of the world
what I typically tell people is right
now in real time if you want to be
predestined if you want to be elect put
your faith in Jesus Christ and you will
but you can also have the comfort that
if you do that that this was not some
accident this was not some afterthought
that God has chosen you in him before
the foundation of the world
the other thing I would say is that
Adventists presents this false dichotomy
that you either
believe in predestination or you don't
and really that's not the issue the
issue is how do you understand
predestination because predestination is
a scriptural word we find it in Romans 8
30 we find it in
yeah there you go
uh what we call the Golden Chain of
Salvation Those whom he predestined he
also called as it says in verse 30. in
addition to that we also find the word
explicitly used in
Ephesians 1 and so it's not a question
of whether or not
as people who take the Bible seriously
we can believe in predestination it's
how we're going to understand it and
obviously amongst true Christian
Believers there's different
understandings of that
but we can't just discard the concept
and say it's unbiblical because it
clearly appears in the Bible
took the words right out of my mouth
that's why I already had it brought up
um sorry Dennis it's there
it's part of the chain of Salvation you
can't just outright dismiss it this is
typically where sdas are going to
falsely assert that's Calvinism
as though John Calvin novelty came up
with predestination
um
no no
right you can't just hold cloth throw
something out there's been discussions
around the mechanics of that Etc but
he's sort of presenting this idea of
like well it's not even a thing at all
I mean except it's literally part of the
chain of salvation but I want to note
before getting into his next portion
here we still haven't actually heard the
gospel
I've heard a lot of theological
disagreements
but not the gospel remember that folks
now I think we will all agree that the
heart and soul of the way God Saves is
not predestination but instead it is
free choice
and based on free choice a completely
different gospel develops
sin what is sin sin in this gospel is
Not an Accident of birth sin is not
having bad equipment inside sin is not
simply being a child of Adam and Eve sin
in this gospel is simply this when you
know the difference between right and
wrong and you deliberately choose what
is wrong you become a sinner a lost
condemned sinner in the eyes of God
when you know what is right and
deliberately choose to defy that and do
it your own way and yes we've all done
that but the key issue how do we become
that way in this gospel by making a
choice not just by being born all right
based on that Jesus Christ when he comes
down to this earth he can take my bad
equipment and not be a sinner so now we
must investigate what the Bible teaches
on this subject and we'll talk about
that as we go on in our study but in
this gospel Jesus Christ can take my
Fallen nature because that is not sin
and he chose to not follow that Fallen
nature during his entire life therefore
he was sinless so the equipment did not
disqualify him it would have been
disloyalty that would have disqualified
him as our savior
and so in this gospel Jesus Christ can
take my nature now we come up to the
crucial Point again justification but
you notice that in this gospel
justification and sanctification are
included not just one or the other
and right here is the crucial difference
between these two gospels I want to try
to refer
so according to Dennis
predestination and free will
are the gospel message
very poor understanding of
predestination because he thinks it
means like he said people don't make
choices or have the capacity to do so
he sets up a false dichotomy of what sin
is again
it's only see in this gospel it's
it's behavioral so well Dennis it can be
both it's not mutually exclusive the
behavior is the fruit of a condition
which is again why you need to look at
the whole of scripture on a subject the
Bible has a lot more to say folks than
just First John 3 regarding what sin is
it's not just I mean even Jesus is
teaching on the law was not just the
letter of the law he expounds upon it
the spirit behind it there's a deeper
implication going on there when he talks
about it's not what goes into a man that
defiles him but what comes out of his
heart again he's talking about these
internal issues that run a lot deeper
than merely the letter of the law
um
is this the gospel Richard so far
nope still haven't heard it
no and any thoughts that you have on
that
well I was just on the on the last thing
I was just thinking it's interesting the
presentation of of um free choice is
though people are in this neutral
state where they just take it or leave
it again it's it's a deficient view of
the nature of man it's not understanding
as Paul says that the natural man
doesn't understand the things of the
spirit of God and he regards them as
foolishness it's a failure to understand
what it means to be dead in trespasses
and sins it's a failure to understand
what it means to be a slave to sin and
so there's this concept that people are
just walking around and if you just hear
a good presentation that
if they just hear that they'll embrace
it and of course we know that that
doesn't that's not how it works out
oftentimes and that's Adventists know
that too but the assumption is there's
just this desire in there to embrace God
and to embrace the gospel and embrace
the truth
and again it's just assumed it's not
built from the scripture on what the
nature of man really is
yeah and like I said I'll have comments
on that here in a moment because when he
again how he's transitioning into theirs
um he'll he'll bring that up here in a
minute so I'll save my comments for
there
your memory again on the First Gospel
the Christian gospel
justification is one hundred percent
Christ's own perfect work done for us
sanctification follows 50 50 as a
Cooperative work I work and God works so
that's the key point of the First Gospel
justification 100 Christ work
sanctification 50 percent Christ's work
now
let's take a look at that very carefully
because that is the key difference
between these two understandings of
salvation
is justification one hundred percent
Christ's work
yes you're exactly right it is it is
there is no other way of Salvation ever
known to mankind
except Jesus Christ
but are there some things you must
believe and do to participate in this
perfect work of Christ for us let's get
very basic right now
do you have to take this book
as more than a collection of 66
interesting stories
you have to believe that it actually is
the product of God's mind sharing his
will with us directly as if you were
here talking to us
is that a big step of faith
I mean there are a lot of books in this
world there are other holy books the
Quran Etc and you're believing that this
book is the only way that God has chosen
to speak his will to mankind
wow that's a big step of faith
tucked away about two-thirds of the way
in this book is a story of one who came
down from heaven lived for over 30 years
on this Earth without even sinning once
and then at the end of his life
experience he died as a criminal and his
death as a criminal is the way of
salvation for anyone who accepts him as
personal savior you have to believe that
too
you talk about a bigger step of Faith
than even believing that this book is
God's voice
those are huge Steps of Faith that you
have to make a decision about
once you've done that once you've
accepted Jesus Christ and the story in
the Bible in the New Testament
then do you have to repent of a passed
away of life that has not been so good
do you have to say I'm sorry the way I
mess things up
if there is someone you have wronged if
there is someone you have misled hurt
their reputation do you have to go to
that person and humbly say I'm sorry
from what I did to you
confess our sins personally
okay so there's the first at least
inkling mention of anything to do with
the person and work of Christ
and we are almost 30 minutes in
but while he's presenting the Christian
Gospel he didn't mention any of that
stuff he mentioned a bunch of stuff
about systematics Richard any thoughts
on that before moving to the next
section
well the whole 50 50 thing on
sanctification he's going to mention
that again
but I was just thinking so obviously he
regards sanctification as a hundred
percent of God and I would agree with
that although I think I'd have a
different definition of sanctification
than he does because he defines it as
all these things
that we're doing but I just want to know
how that computes that he mentions all
these things we have to do but then says
it's a hundred percent of God how does
that go together
well it does well it doesn't and we're
going to look at some quotes later from
his prophetess that show it doesn't
um but you'll see here in a moment folks
why he's wanting to uh position it that
way
do you have to make a complete 100
surrender of your life to Jesus Christ
well those are all big steps aren't they
not easy steps let's say for a moment
that you do all those things you believe
the Bible you believe Jesus Christ you
uh you repent you confess your sins you
surrender your life and for just a
moment imagine with me that Jesus never
really did die on the cross that that
didn't happen how far how much is all
that going to get you
zero is that right
so yes Jesus Christ the only way of
Salvation is one hundred percent Jesus
death on the cross isn't it that is the
key issue and right here most Christians
do not understand what I'm going to
share with you next
there is a difference between the cause
of Salvation and the conditions of
salvation
most Christians don't want to hear about
conditions
conditions of Salvation the cause of
Salvation is the grace of God and the
life and death of Jesus Christ that's
the cause of Salvation there is no other
cause
but there are conditions to
participating in that 100 work of Jesus
Christ and we've just gone through a few
of those big Steps of Faith big
decisions about your life those are
conditions they don't earn you salvation
they don't get you salvation you don't
deserve salvation because you have done
those things but without those things
you can't be saved
and that Christians find a hard time
getting their minds around
they all they say well then that's Works
no it isn't work in the sense of human
works because the only salvation is
Jesus Christ but the only way to
participate in that is cooperation
that's the word cooperation with God's
way if this is the way Lord then I want
to participate in it not to deserve
anything but because this is the way you
have outlined if I'm to be baptized that
doesn't earn me my salvation but I want
to participate in the way you have
suggested that I come into a new birth
experience
and so all of these conditions of
Salvation are the key issues right here
it's just the way God's outlined Richard
it's just how God's outlined the way to
be saved that's all
that your list Dennis is way longer than
what I read in the Bible
and think of Romans 4 5 to him who does
not work but believes in him who
justifies the ungodly his faith is
counted as righteousness I think of the
Philippian Jailer and
falling down and saying to the apostles
sirs what must I do to be saved not some
long list of conditions is given to them
he is told believe in the Lord Jesus
Christ and you will be saved
and so Dennis
where's all your conditions in the
scripture the scripture says faith alone
well nav and a system of salvation's
Novel to the 19th century
yet that's how God outlined salvation
happens I mean Dennis
your church is on record saying that
your guys's gospel message is novel to
you guys
they literally have people JL Schuler in
the 30s reviewing Harold saying this
gospel message that we have which is
what he's putting forth tonight
was not preached by the apostles
the church fathers the medieval fathers
the reformers no one else only them
but that's how God has outlined
salvation
I'm sensing some present truth here with
uh going on in Dennis's way of of seeing
things okay now he's going to move into
Sabbath keeping
let's um
take it another step
sanctification
remember the First Gospel says that's 50
percent Christ's work and 50 percent my
work let's take Sabbath keeping as an
example let's say you're very careful
about your Sabbath keeping that you
precisely end your business activities
before Sundown on Friday evening you do
not carry business into the Sabbath you
have a good Friday evening experience
with the Lord on Sabbath morning you are
in church Sabbath afternoon you are
doing work for the Lord you closed the
Sabbath on Friday evening on Sabbath
evening does that make you a Sabbath
keeper and I'm going to say no it
doesn't
it makes you a Saturday keeper
who are the best Saturday Keepers this
world has ever known
the Pharisees I mean they were very
careful they had rules for everything
they were not going to break the Sabbath
under any condition in any way they're
going to make sure that they had
boundaries all the way around the
Sabbath so the Sabbath Holiness could
not be touched and you know what Jesus
had to spend an inordinate amount of his
ministry trying to turn Saturday Keepers
into Sabbath keepers
so what's a Sabbath keeper
some people
in the Christian World misidentify us
they get our name wrong
they call us seven day Adventists have
you heard that
you seven day Adventists
they may be more right than we realize
wow if we aren't an Adventist a
Christian on Tuesday you can forget
about the Sabbath as a holy day
if we aren't a Christian seven days out
of the week
then there is no Sabbath keeping
possible for us only Saturday keeping
he measures the Pharisees
Dennis you mean like this
folks you can go to the site type this
in what did Ellen White add to the
Sabbath command
I mean look at all these
and those are just the ones that I've
documented there's probably more than
that
now they'll respond like I say in the
article here they'll respond to this
rank legalism by claiming context in
which Ellen White lived was different
many of these tasks they required tons
of Labor and it would keep one from
resting yada yada but the point being
the Pharisees
Dennis that that's literally what you
guys are
that is what you guys are
thoughts on that and did you did you
catch where he said Jesus spent his
ministry trying to make
Saturday Keepers into Sabbath Keepers
yeah
yeah it's just like what what
again their whole system though of
course revolves around the seventh day
Sabbath you know and so great
controversy theme right you know it's
the end time testing truth it's the
thing that God is supposedly so
concerned about above above all others
and yet
Christ is said to have come to turn
Saturday Keepers into Sabbath Keepers I
just want to know where this emphasis is
in the gospels we have four gospels
where is this emphasis that that's what
his ministry was trying to do was make
Sabbath Keepers out of the Pharisees
well and it's just one of those things
it's like it's Peak adventism to say
like these like pithy sort of things
like
these people said this comment about us
so
they may be more right than we
understand
Jesus's Ministry was based on making
Saturday Keepers Sabbath Keepers and
it's like oh yeah that really you know
that's so insightful but no then you
examine it it's like well no
well
what are you talking about Jesus was
rebuking people that had a bunch of
man-made Traditions the Corban rule for
example and was rebuking them for adding
all of these additions and missing the
greater point which is exactly what
adventism has done
like almost identically so
exactly
because you see the Sabbath is a holy
day isn't it
and how can an Unholy person keep a holy
day
that's impossible
and so only one who has been made Holy
by the process of sanctification can
keep a holy day in any way
who does the work of making someone holy
Holy Spirit
Jesus Christ
so the work of changing a person
inwardly
so that they reflect the image of Jesus
Christ and Are Holy From the Inside Out
is the work of Christ and the Holy
Spirit
100 percent
yeah 100 percent you don't contribute to
that do you have to cooperate with that
are there conditions to that
so you see we have conditions and cause
again conditions of Sabbath keeping are
stopping your work on Friday evening but
that does not make you holy
the work of Holiness is bigger than that
and precedes that
and so I'm going to say that the
Christian Gospel has made a tragic
mistake when it says that the work of
sanctification is 50 percent my work
no it isn't it's 100 percent Christ's
work God's work the holy spirit's work
100 percent
and we participate in it
I'm going to use another illustration
right here to kind of uh set this in
perspective
okay
oh
did you notice the flip-flopping
specifically on the day being holy but
not really because it's only holy if the
individual is leading up to it or wholly
and set apart previously said or
previously he said if you aren't an
Adventist on Monday Tuesday Etc you can
forget about the Sabbath being a holy
day but then he says the Sabbath is a
holy day isn't it so how can an Unholy
person keep a holy day
total
uh non-distinction of like you got
blundered up there Dennis but then this
claim like you mentioned earlier the
Christian gospel
is that sanctification is 50 man and 50
God Dennis where are you getting this
earlier he tried to make it sound like
Christians don't think sanctification is
really a thing at all
now he says they do but it's a 50 50
split
again let's just use the Westminster
Confession as an example
since you and I align closest with that
um but again we could look at others
does this sound anything like he's
claiming
Westminster Confession chapter 13 of
sanctification
they who are effectually called and
regenerated having a new heart and a new
spirit created in them
are further Sanctified really and
personally
through the virtue of Christ's death and
Resurrection by his word and Spirit
dwelling in them the Dominion of the
whole body of sin is destroyed and the
several lusts thereof are more and more
weakened and mortified and they're more
and more quickened and strengthened in
all saving Graces to the practice of
true Holiness without which no man shall
see the Lord
this sanctification is throughout in the
whole man yet imperfect in this life
there abide it's still some remnants of
corruption in every part once it rises a
continual and irreconcilable War the
flesh lusting against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh
in which war although the remaining
corruption for a time May much Prevail
yet through the continual supply of the
strength from the sanctifying spirit of
Christ
the regenerate part doth overcome and so
the Saints grow in Grace perfecting
Holiness in the fear of God
so they're Sanctified by what
the word and the spirit of God
that's 100 God
so Dennis you're wrong sir
he said it's a hundred percent God's
work but we participate in it that
sounds a lot closer to a 50 50. than
what we just read
and what we read is actually 100 God's
work according to the confession we
could look at others and we're going to
talk about their view of sanctification
a little bit more later so I'll save my
other comments for then Richard any
thoughts that you have on that well but
but because it mentions that there's
still you know some abiding remnants of
corruption in Us in this life why that's
not really full sanctification don't you
know
right if you can't achieve glorification
now it means that you don't think
glorification will come at any point but
then again they mystifying glorification
so that's where the the issue rubs but
that's essentially what the confession
is getting at there is that which we're
going to look at that later as well um
what the confession has to say about
glorification and that it's basically
just stating when it says that not this
idea oh it's making a loophole for sin
that's what you'll hear oh so it's
making Provisions to just live however
you want it's like this get out of jail
free card type thing no that's not what
it's doing it's it's recognizing the
timeline like you said that God has an
order and they're trying to basically
short circuit that so now he's going to
give an example of a testimony
and this is just
this says it all says it all say in
church you come to church one day and
you listen to a marvelous testimony the
person in church is giving a testimony
of how Jesus has forgiven his sins how
he's having a good walk with the Lord he
prays he studies his Bible he's what
he's out witnessing he's doing things
that really bring him happiness and joy
and peace and he just spends 10 minutes
praising God for the work that God has
done in his life and you stand back
amazed I want that experience I want to
know how he's getting how he's doing
that I want to get it get acquainted
with him so one day you follow him home
from church
and you notice a strange thing when he
gets out of his car at his house he's
yelling at the kids they must have
ticked him off on the way home somehow
and that's not very good so he's yelling
at them and their faults all the way up
the sidewalk he yells at the kids his
wife steps in to kind of blunt the force
of his anger and she gets the brunt of
his anger as well he's yelling at her
too and by the time they get to the
front door he's even pushed his wife
what do you think is there something
wrong with that marvelous justification
experience
sanctification doesn't seem quite up to
par does it
let's turn it around
let's say there's a person in church who
is a very careful Sabbath keeper very
careful in tithes and offerings very
careful in high standards Health reform
all of the things that make a lifestyle
of an Adventist
but when you talk to that person there
is no joy in his heart
there is no peace there is no happiness
he kind of hangs his head and he says
I've got to do all these things because
if I don't do them I'm going to end up
in hell and I don't want to go there so
I'm going to grit my teeth and I'm going
to keep the Sabbath
what do you think is there something
wrong with that experience
sanctification looks good on the outside
doesn't it but where is the
justification where is the joy of
forgiveness where is the happiness that
comes from a living relationship with
Jesus Christ
so what I'm saying is that these two
justification and sanctification must
work precisely in harmony with each
other
they must be in cooperation if there is
going to be any genuine salvation it's
not justification up here in
sanctification as coming along for the
ride justification is not the engine and
sanctification the Caboose
these are part and parcel of one saving
process and God does both of them
while we cooperate with them and fulfill
certain conditions that's my
understanding of how the gospel works
and that's what the difference the
primary difference between these two
gospels justification in the First
Gospel is all that matters in the second
gospel sanctification is as crucial as
justification
now if God can justify us one hundred
percent
and if he can sanctify us 100 percent
then is it just remotely possible that
God can perfect us 100 percent
and I said God can
that he can do the impossible and so
that last step in this gospel says
Perfection of character is possible
before Jesus comes
okay there are so many issues with his
example
which actually makes for a perfect
example of how the SDA system has no
concept of a person's war with sin
it had no understanding of nuance
whatsoever Dennis what about if this
person was remorseful after doing this
what if this person has been a
born-again Believer for one week and
they're an infant in the faith
what about if that encounter leads to
his wife reaching out to the elders the
elders then come and exercise church
discipline the man's remorseful and God
uses it as a big boost in his walk with
Christ and his sanctification
I mean there's so many nuances to that
that's like
see in their understanding though it's
like oh see any slip up it's revoked
like all of a sudden you have no you
have no Union with Christ I guess some
of them could say well that person never
had Union with Christ okay but the
majority of them are going to say well
that person in that moment they became
disowned because the Bible says Union
with Christ brings about Holiness blank
like you're holy blameless uh set apart
you're redeemed you're I mean there's so
many things and we've talked about this
on the channel before but one of those
is adopted so in Dennis's view any
little thing at any possible moment God
is just waiting and watching because
apparently he's not all-knowing either
that's the logical ends of this they'd
he'd be an open theist if he was
consistent
that God's just waiting and watching for
any moment and any slip up any oh it's
revoked now
that's the sort of thing that's being
presented there and that was the
testimony of I don't know how many
Adventists I've talked to that's exactly
what they were presented with that God
is a figure with the father has like
steam pouring out of his ears and he's
angry and the Sun is kind of standing in
between as the soft sort of passive
figure that's trying to calm him down
and you just have this angry God who's
just waiting to fly off the handle kind
of at any moment that's the sort of
thing that he presented there there's so
much Nuance in all that that's like Dude
you are completely missing it like
people war with sin yeah there are sins
that people struggle with
for long periods of time sometimes
the point is is that they are warring
with it that's something that doesn't
happen with the unbeliever
the unbeliever doesn't war with sin they
don't have conviction of sin and this
does go back to again not the gospel but
his just faulty understanding of
anthropology the nature of man
um because he has no concept of that
that war going on
but because of what he said
if that's even happening
any of that stuff he mentioned you have
a bunk testimony you obviously haven't
been changed
because there could be still still sins
that you're at war with
yet I know countless people early on
that word with certain sins by virtue of
being born again and now having and now
having conviction
they war with that particular sin and it
lasts sometimes for a long time but
according to Dennis that entire year
that person was at war with that sin
they weren't actually a believer
that hadn't been a hundred percent
Sanctified at the moment of accepting
Christ type thing
what he described is pietism
not Christianity
pietism he said this person's reading
their Bible they're praying they're out
witnessing doing things that bring them
Joy Etc
but then when you follow him home at his
house you see he exudes Behavior that's
not in line with those other things
that's literally just pietism
just because somebody's doing those
things that's not what you look to to
say well that person's a Christian
because they are because they are doing
this and that and they're reading their
Bible each day and you know if you if
you read your Bible this many times and
you go to church this many times all of
that stuff gets into pietism that's
that's not what automatically makes
somebody a Christian but it's a perfect
insight into the Adventist understanding
of
what a testimony is they love having
people I don't know if the churches you
were at they love having people come and
share your testimony because they want
to have hopefully some other person
there will hear about how the Adventist
message just radically changed their
life and it'll make people just fall in
love with adventism even more any
thoughts on on any of that
well there's no concept
I mean there is a concept but it's
losing your salvation there's no concept
that God works with his people that we
are in his family he is our father and
like a good father you know if my kids
disobey me I don't open the front door
and Booth them on the street
um
you know as the scripture says is God
says as many as I love I rebuke and
chasten
yeah
yeah and so God is
it's not that you know there's just a
get out of jail free card so to speak if
we sin the Lord does chastise he does
rebuke the word is clear about that but
we're not going to be cast out I mean
Dennis what do you do with John 6 37 the
one who comes to me I will never cast
out
I mean and yet every time we sin in this
system we're going to be cast out
the other thing I thought about earlier
and I want to bring it up now is we
actually have a Biblical example of a
man who fell into heinous sin in David
and how God dealt with that God didn't
cast him off to perish God sent a
messenger to David to
bring him to a conviction of his sin and
to bring him to repentance
and so we actually have an example of
how this works
can can God's people can save people
fall into heinous sin at times yes but
is God going to leave us there no nope
God is going to draw us back to
repentance
yeah and it it just apply the Psalms the
things that David says in the Psalms to
this sort of thing that he's putting
forth all the times David and asaph are
lamenting over their sin
well that shouldn't be happening
in the the life of the the believer
right
well there's different times they
lamented and mourned over their sin and
so all that's all those times was them
just going back and forth back and forth
God is just
that's not a stable way of living that's
not a stable way of understanding that's
that's not like you said that's not
what's going on because God chastises
his children that said over and over in
scripture did you notice that he
Associates sanctification with living
the Adventist lifestyle
which would include diet theology tithe
Seventh-Day sabitarianism Etc again
getting this from Ellen White
thoughts on what he said regarding
sanctification and justification
well yeah I've been thinking about about
what you mentioned you know the whole
for some time now you know of
associating sanctification
with Adventist standards
I could tell my own personal testimony
about that as I'm sure others who have
come out of adventism can that
you know as clothing and and
these other things he mentions you know
jewelry and whatnot became less of an
issue
other things
we're becoming more and more of an issue
as an Adventist I had no qualms about
gossip
for example and as I learned the gospel
I was more and more convicted in fact I
remember
one day I was meeting with a Christian
man
and I was I started gossiping about
someone in the community
and this was right when I was in the
transition Point transitioning from
adventism into the true gospel
and
this man's response
you know I I shared how this other
person had
had approached me in a red hot Fury and
then
you know as soon as I moved toward him
he backed off and apologized to me and
and you know my thought was you know
well he was he was afraid because he
approaches me in this Fury and then I
move toward him and he doesn't even know
me this guy that did this this was a
neighbor scenario and a place I was
working
but anyway I told this story to this
Christian man
and he immediately says well that's
great that guy apologized to you and
here I'm
gossiping and thinking it's funny and
this guy's this guy was a low life to to
approach me in this rage
and then back off from it and yet it
pricked me in the heart at that very
moment
about this behavior that I was perfectly
comfortable with as an Adventist
you know of just assuming these bad
things about people just
airing people's dirty laundry to others
who had nothing to do with it and this
Christian man's response of praise to
the other man pricked me in the heart
and convicted me over sins I had never
even been convicted over before
yeah well it's like he's again like he
was saying earlier he's kind of looting
at the same thing here it's like well
Christians don't believe in
sanctification they demean it it's like
down here it's not it's like Dennis
you're not dealing with the the issue at
least not historically I I don't know
any movement historically I mean that's
been orthodox right um outside of
Orthodoxy you can find anything but
within like Orthodox Christian T I can't
find anyone who just says no
sanctification is not a thing again we
don't do the thing like Dennis does with
oh predestination that's that no that's
not in the Bible just throw that out
entirely we're not doing that with
sanctification the problem is is rightly
understanding it's it's function its use
its category that sort of thing but all
of that to say folks this is what they
actually teach he's not getting into the
finer details but this is what they
teach about sanctification and
justification okay
it's from Ellen White's faith in Works
page 99 we've looked at this before
quote while God can be just and yet
justify The Sinner through the merits of
Christ no man can cover his soul with
the garments of Christ righteousness
while practicing known sins or
neglecting known duties God requires the
entire surrender of the heart before
justification can take place and in
order for man to retain justification
there must be continual obedience
through active Living Faith that works
by love and purifies the soul she
continues
it was impossible for The Sinner to keep
the law of God which was wholly just and
good but this impossibility was removed
by the impartation of the righteousness
of Christ to the repenting believing
Soul the life and death of Christ in
behalf of sinful men
are sinful man were for the purpose of
restoring The Sinner to God's favor
through imparting to him the
righteousness that would meet the claims
of the law and find acceptance with the
father elsewhere back in the book sons
and daughters
quote
when it is in the heart to obey God when
efforts are put forth to this end Jesus
accepts this disposition and effort as
man's best service
and he makes up for the deficiency with
his own Divine Merit
sounds a lot like 50 50 to me Dennis
no kids they'll say they'll say no no
it's all Jesus is married I just
participate and cooperate
like he was saying earlier it's just
cooperation participation
but get that their model of
sanctification is you put forth your
best efforts and disposition Jesus's
Divine merits are then imparted you to
make up the rest and each day this
effort is what maintains your
justification
that is what Dennis technically means
when he's saying by participation
cooperation it's just conditions stuff
works
it's just conditions Richard what does
this say about their understanding of
Holiness and the standard think about
that think about that you can be made
right with the one true God
by giving your best efforts and then
Jesus will fill in where you fall short
so God is a compromiser God will accept
some yeah halfway Holiness where I do my
best and he makes up the rest and notice
it's it they use that word impartace she
uses that word impartation over and over
again because
to them
you have to get holy through imparted or
internal
righteousness and he mentioned that a
little bit ago
about
when he mentioned the Sabbath you know
that I have to be holy
inwardly in order to keep the Sabbath
holy again there's no
it's it's skipping over
what I mentioned earlier in in Romans 4
5 which was to him who does not work but
believes in him who justifies the
ungodly his faith is counted or credited
as righteousness
and so God doesn't compromise on
holiness
Jesus Christ the perfect Holy One
we receive his Holiness his
righteousness the second we come into
Faith the second we come into Union
with him it's not some you know halfway
thing where I'm doing my best to get
internally righteousness and that's what
God accepts no it's only Jesus Christ
in his Perfection that God will accept
and that's why we have to be hidden in
Christ
there are so many problems with their
their theory on this like the idea that
Christ's righteousness doesn't perfect
like you can have the atoning benefits
applied to some degree but then they're
not actually effectual to the consistent
ends like the author of Hebrews tells us
that Christ sacrifice those it was made
for it perfects
and in this system you have this idea of
like well you're getting the benefits
like partially given to you gradually
over time in accordance with your
cooperation and that's not how Paul
describes justification or imputation
for that matter Dennis
the way that Ellen White described that
there that is not the way that the
Apostle Paul describes either of those
things
what Dennis really means is that the SDA
Church affirms a two-tier system of
justification initial and final or as
some of them will say eschatological
that's what he means by justification
and sanctification are side by side
he said in the First Gospel that's
supposed to be us sanctification doesn't
matter yet did the Westminster
Confession of Faith say that did it say
sanctification doesn't matter
it says without Holiness No One's Gonna
See the Lord what are you talking about
just like crazy statements like that
like in that First Gospel sanctification
doesn't matter and see that's why these
sdas who are being influenced by this
they're downplaying sanctification no
those people are probably caught in
limbo of confusion of like
they hear some truth over here and then
they're trying to meld it with and parse
through their own tradition and their
own experience there's a number of
variables going on with that but
nevertheless know that the the
mainstream Orthodox Christian Gospel uh
is not poo pooing on sanctification
um and and yet again I'll just say the
last thing here before moving to this
next part
um he needs to deal with being born dead
in sins and trespasses
like you've mentioned this a number of
times I've mentioned it uh Dennis you
need to deal with it that has to do with
a person's nature I'm going to share
with you a little illustration that I
think you'll enjoy God works like an
infinitely skillful physician he can
save and heal anyone who trusts him he
is not at all satisfied when we come to
his office just to be forgiven he
proposes to bring us to the place where
we won't have to ask for forgiveness
anymore he offers to heal that place
where people do their thinking
then they won't violate those rules
anymore because they don't even want to
and all the bad habits are gone
to some that sounds ominously like
perfection
servants see these they see this as a
command friends see it as a promise
friends don't want God to settle for
anything less would you ask a physician
not to heal you completely would you say
75 healing will be quite sufficient
thank you
two servants who think of Salvation as
dealing with their legal problems
Perfection is yet another requirement to
friends who think of Salvation as
healing the damage sin has done
Perfection is an incredibly generous
offer
servants want to be completely forgiven
friends want to be completely healed
about that matter of perfection the
Heavenly physician might call after us
as we walk away from his office don't
worry about it I've so designed my
universe that it's a law people become
like the person they worship and admire
if you really stay my trusting friends
Perfection will come I'm not saying you
won't struggle anymore but the struggle
won't be the same
my friends if there's any hope for this
elusive dream of perfection that
Seventh-Day Adventists talk about and is
so maligned throughout the Christian
world has got to be something like that
healing by the great physician total
healing Total Restoration total change
in our lives
again with the caricatures
what a disastrous illustration who is
saying people won't receive a full
healing
again you're completely misplacing
glorification Dennis Romans 8 30 you're
over realizing the timeline
because in your system there could be
people that achieve glorification
tomorrow by finally the guy the SDA
who's since the 70s he's been working on
he's on the the process tomorrow
September 15th 2023 that now becomes the
day that he arrives Bonk there he's now
arrived at glorification in this life
you should have all sorts of people like
that they've been on the Trek for 45
years where are you at Dennis how close
are you
had you arrived at glorification yet
that's what they're saying in their
systems that you can arrive at
glorification now
but also he doesn't realize that both of
man's faculties and will
impacted by the Fall both man's
faculties and will were impacted by the
full
did you catch his book at sin being a
legal problem
oh yeah take it up with Jesus then
Dennis
because he said in the Lord's Prayer
read the parallel accountings folks
Matthew 6 Luke 11. he equates sin with
debt
it's one of the categories of that's one
of the ways that that sin is described
in scripture which is why on the article
on our site we explain that in Greater
detail I brought that up earlier you can
check it out on our website what is sin
he also balked at the idea of being a
servant of Christ did you catch that
he used this illusion or illustration of
uh servant versus friend he said
servants want to be completely forgiven
friends want to be completely heal
healed
why is that a dichotomy yeah but two
uh Romans 1 1.
Paul had no issue with being seen as a
servant of Jesus Christ
I don't recall Paul saying a friend of
Jesus Christ
I'm not really sure what the point of
his analogy is except that
it's not biblical and it isn't logically
sound but also
Ellen White had no issue viewing people
as servants over and against friends
when she said stuff like this
quote
Christian Temperance and Bible hygiene
every true Christian will have control
of his appetites and passions unless
he's free from the bondage of appetite
he cannot be a true obedient
servant of Christ
the Indulgence of appetite and passion
blunts the effects of Truth upon the
heart
so I'm not sure what his point is in
this analogy of like
see these people that view sin that way
they just want to be off the hook
whereas those of us that view God like a
friend we understand that he wants to
heal us
what again no no concept of Union with
Christ like at all and all the benefits
that come with that it's just you're
over realizing where we're at in the
timeline what are your thoughts on that
and if we don't believe that the healing
is done a hundred percent here and now
in this life you know we just we don't
believe in it at all we don't want it at
all I mean again I go back to what I
said earlier of short-circuiting God's
process
I mean our Jesus told us
you mentioned the Lord's Prayer a minute
ago he told us to pray forgive us our
debts as we forgive our debtors
um was it Christ's goal to say well pray
this until you
shortly here after you're going to reach
this state where you're no longer going
to need to pray this
I I put up a video on that months ago
and I knew it was going to ruffle the
feathers I knew it was
and I was like I want to see if a single
Seventh Adventist will address this not
a single one of them did they all said
you took Ellen out of context you don't
know what you're saying you're there
you're angry you're here it's been
months I've tried to respond to almost
every comment at least that I get
notified on that particular video
um and I've told every one of them
you guys aren't taking up Jesus's words
Jesus is the one that when his disciples
asked how do we pray and Jesus taught
them
a daily prayer which includes asking
forgiveness for your sins
oh so you're saying there's a license to
sin
I'm just saying that that's what Jesus
said so you have you have to deal with
that you can't just
well John over here says this okay so
set Jesus's words against John
great solution that doesn't change what
Jesus said in the Lord's Prayer so how
do you understand what Jesus is saying
in the Lord's Prayer I had one person
that tried to reach out that said
well
okay if what you're saying is true what
about that day it says for us to uh
uh forgive us our sins as we have sinned
against others what if you haven't
sinned against somebody else that day
okay thank you for thank you for proving
the point sir
it doesn't deal with the fact that Jesus
said it's a daily prayer and part of
that daily prayer includes
forgive us our sins and Jesus parallels
the two accountings of that with debts
even in Luke and Luke he actually says
forgive us our uh I believe he says sins
and debts in the same the same stanza
and so all that to say that uh
yeah now he's going to move into a
disastrous illustration number two
came across this little statement which
I thought really summarizes everything
we're talking about now the First Gospel
the Christian Gospel can be summarized
by one word and the word is forgiveness
if you're forgiven you're saved that's
the gospel
we can summarize this gospel with one
word also
and the word is restoration
restoration this emphasis makes
Seventh-day Adventist theology unique
remember the question what is special
about Seventh-Day adventism what makes
adventism different
it's Restoration in the gospel not just
forgiveness not just making sure that
your forgiveness of sins is up to date
and then you're okay
but complete and total healing
restoration marrying strange theology
with Adventist theology can justifiably
be described as Patchwork Theology and
oh my friends for 30 years and More in
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church we have
been patching together Our Gospel with
the Christian Gospel and we have got the
worst hodgepodge that I have ever seen
in my lifetime
Patchwork theology doesn't work
all kinds of people want a third tree I
put two trees on your diagram people
want a third tree which patches together
these two Gospels
it isn't possible not logically not
consistently and not biblically
I mean I appreciate his honesty around
these Christianity and adventism are not
the same thing I noticed they always
tack on uh and you probably noticed this
as well they'll always tack on
Seventh-day Adventist Christians
you're not just a Christian you're a
Seventh-Day Adventist Christian because
that's really where the identity lies so
I'm glad that he's at least honest about
that but yes Christianity and adventism
do not meld at all it's its own thing
they need to own that
um and that's been part of the the
mission behind this in terms of the
pressure on the Adventist organization
is to own up to these sorts of things
more like Mr Priebe is
um but he said the Christian gospel
what he presented as the Christian
Gospel is only about forgiveness of sins
the Adventist gospel is about Total
Restoration
now Dennis the only restoration that's
relevant and valid about your guys's
gospel is the fact that you think the
true gospel and the church completely
fell away and you guys are restoring it
that's how it's a restorative gospel
it's part of these restorationist ideas
that the Pioneers coming from the
Christian connection a restorationist
group brought with them into millerism
and then into Seventh-Day adventism but
that's about the only aspect of
restoration that's going on in your
guys's gospel because exhibit a of the
SDA church is very uh you know this is a
perfect example of the SDA church is
very weak theology around New Creation
I mean if being made a new creature in
Christ isn't restoration I'm not sure
what is
and actually no they don't teach
restoration
again their Resurrection model is
cloning
so Dennis isn't isn't going into that
because this is in an area that I've
seen a ton of pressure put on in regards
to Adventist theology about how wrong
and off it is
they don't teach restoration their
Resurrection model isn't even a
resurrection it's not going to be the
self-same body that went into the ground
like Paul says
what's sown is then raised they teach
it's a completely different body that
God will make and import your character
or personality into that was preserved
in his memory into that new body such
that you can be recognized that's not
restoration
that's called a starting over a plan B A
Try over because even in their redo of
Eden that they think they're on the path
towards it isn't Zion
Mount Zion is an unshakable Kingdom but
in their model it's a back to Eden's
status again
it will be rendered secure
because you'll have demonstrated here
while on probation that you can be
trusted
it's a do-over it's not a restoration
the true restoration is the second atom
that did what the first Adam failed to
do who came to redeem the creation did
so successfully by making it new
now he rules and Reigns over it as he
subdues all things and his enemies are
being made a footstool again fulfilling
what the first Adam was supposed to do
and take Dominion
that's true restoration
it's actually more of a more than a
restoration it's a massive upgrade
because Zion is far better than Eden
Abraham was not looking forward folks or
looking back rather
for the better Promised Land being back
in Eden he was looking forward to that
better Promised Land
Zion
but then two
restoration is not what makes adventism
unique
the great controversy theme is what
makes adventism unique unique it's The
Binding glue of the organization and
everyone in it now I'm sure he means
their Sanctuary model of cleansing which
is you know
totally unique to them
the apostles didn't preach at the early
church the medieval Church the reformers
that's how unique it is
but that system most certainly is not
restorative
it's LED millions of people to hell it's
deceived millions of souls confused
countless Minds it's committed spiritual
murder of who knows how many people
that's not restorative it is a false
gospel and Paul says any other gospels
than the one given by Christ to the
apostles is cursed damned Galatians 1.
they openly state in their official
Publications the apostles didn't preach
the SDA gospel he clearly hears saying
the Adventist gospel is a unique to
Adventist gospel making it a false
gospel it's cursed
it's anything but restorative
and then again even though he hasn't
given the Christian Gospel he straight
up says adventism has a different gospel
thank you Dennis for your honesty
there you go when I get people that say
I'm lying I'm misrepresenting we don't
know what we're talking about no I know
very well what I'm talking about my
friend
Dennis is actually honest enough to
admit it and say it assuredly
it is not Christian
they may tack on the word Christian to
Seventh-Day Adventists periodically
and he did that earlier like I'm like I
mentioned Seventh Adventist Christians
but they are Seventh-day Adventists that
is what they predominantly refer to
themselves as being a Seventh-Day
Adventist is the identity not
Christianity any thoughts on that before
moving to this uh third to last section
well the biggest thing that jumped out
at me and what he said was his summary
of the Christian Gospel being
forgiveness versus the Adventist gospel
being restoration
no the Christian Gospel is Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ
and everything he has done it is
entirely sufficient the Adventist gospel
as Dennis has been outlining is Jesus
Christ plus my cooperation with him in
following all the Adventist rules and
standards
make no mistake about it
the Christian Gospel is Jesus Christ in
the Adventist gospel is Jesus Plus
good stuff Street
so my friends I do believe there's a
crucial issue at stake let's take a
brief look at what happens in the fruits
of this tree
the judgment is a judgment necessary in
this gospel
if there are two people in church who
look like they're doing the same thing
they are there to all outroad
appearances the same but God can see
Into the Heart of one that that one is
is making it up is making a pretense of
it and the other one is a genuine
doesn't that need some opening of books
and examining of Live And motive and
activities so that everyone can see why
one person would be happy and joyful in
heaven and the other person would find
it a living hell for the rest of
Eternity
isn't a judgment necessary to answer
questions that human beings and even
angels can't understand
because only God can read the motives of
the heart
and what has happened in their
experience so a judgment becomes
crucially important not as an opposition
to the gospel but as a demonstration of
the gospel and how the gospel really is
our salvation
Ellen G white
I came across this statement from Dwight
Nelson as you may have seen some of his
programs on net or whatever
if you've been in The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church very long at all you've
been tempted to not believe in this
Prophet stuff in today's religious
environment it's embarrassing to be
different it's embarrassing to have a
prophet in your movement you're
considered a bit odd a little strange
and so we have gone quiet about Ellen
White without any Fanfare or apology
we've simply gone silent
don't quote her from the pulpit we
admonish each other just read the word
didn't she give some counsel to that
effect
but the time has come this close to the
end of Earth civilization to re-examine
reflect re-study and recommit ourselves
to the mission and message of that woman
the most prolific female author in the
history of the human race it's time to
stop apologizing for her Ministry both
in our own movement and outside of it
and I say well said well said
we don't need to apologize or to feel
second-class citizens because God chose
to give us help at the end of time
and then after all those good things he
really stepped on our toes hard he said
we shouldn't call these the red books
they're really the unread books
wow
so he literally says
the visible Church demonstrates the need
for 1844 in the investigative judgment I
mean for real
again we get the straw man
representation of what Christians
believe about judgment
positioning it as though we reject all
judgment outright again Dennis despite
this pesky document that just kind of
transcends all borders uh the Apostles
Creed
but then his whole idea of judgment is
filtered through again the great
controversy theme
everyone needs to see why one person
would be joyful in heaven and another
wouldn't
where does the bible say this this is
like a huge permeating thing I used to
hear all about in adventism about their
you know in their seminars when they're
talking about or even sermons when
they're talking about what heaven's
going to be like
and of course they're not Consulting the
Bible because the Bible doesn't go into
a lot of these great details but one of
the key things that they're all looking
forward to is uh the Thousand-Year
Millennial reign of fact checking as I
call it they'll be fact checking God's
doing in the words of Stephen Bohr to be
able to sign to give a sigh of relief
and say okay we can trust him
he literally says that
none of that is biblical
they read into phrases like books being
opened
anywhere they'll see that and they can
insert all of this record-keeping
inspection that they're going to do
about Grandma and a cousin or whomever
he said judgment is for questions to be
answered that people cannot understand
and since God can see the heart he can
answer them and that's supposed to be
not in opposition to the gospel but as a
demonstration of the Gospel
Dennis it's a part of the Adventist
Church's false gospel
it literally is a part of the Gospel
reviewing Herald States over and over
again that the apostles didn't preach
your gospel
you've tried labeling some of your
guys's gospel as merely fruit of the
Gospel
when no the stuff you're labeling as
fruit is absolutely part of the SDA
gospel it should all be on the trunk
it's not just oh the fruits of this like
Foundation down here which is what a lot
of them try and position as they love to
say that we're just the consistent ends
of methodism
or just consistent arminianism and
that's kind of what he's doing here by
putting all this you know sort of stuff
that's kind of found in methodism down
in the trunk and that's the platform and
Foundation when no dude the stuff that
you're labeling is fruit is absolutely a
part of the SDA gospel it literally is
your gospel as we will see once they're
all listed once he gets to all of them
but they like to point to stuff in the
tree trunk and say Edmonton's just
consistent methodism no no it's not but
then
did Richard did God give Ellen White as
a help at the end of time
that's quite the way of putting it yeah
it's pretty funny isn't it
as though um
you know people at the End of Time need
this special help that nobody ever
needed in history before this supposed
special help this supposed
lesser light so to speak yeah it's like
why you know the other interesting thing
too is you know uh
this uh a Bible that's two inches thick
versus her stack of books that if you
stack him up are as tall as a grown man
Okay so
everyone in Redemptive history all of
God's people before could just get by
without all these thousands of
additional pages of information but now
it's needed
yeah it's just like and I when I first
heard this the first thing I thought was
so for help to his church
God gave a christological heretic and
false prophet at the end of time
to help out who exactly
what he used he gave the gift of the
church to clear everything up and to
abandon the Creeds abandon irenaeus all
the greats that came before us you know
the shoulders of giants that God has
literally given to the church to help
Propel you know things forward no no no
we're supposed to throw all that out
throw out the Creeds throw out the
confessions start over reinvent the
wheel
and he gave this christological heretic
who couldn't Exige her way out of a wet
paper bag
who
under her own admission
would be sitting in the room while
they're studying the word of God and was
dull of hearing that's her own words
couldn't understand a lick of what they
were saying
who then gave numerous false prophecies
claimed to be shown the day in the hour
or given the day in the hour on multiple
occasions falsely gave all sorts of
other failed prophecies and contradicts
the word of God constantly Genesis 3 6
being the big one I always point to
Adventist you still haven't dealt with
it it says Adam was there with Eve deal
with it it says what it says he was
there with Eve don't give me the oh well
he he he couldn't have been there
because if he would have been then this
would have been the conclusion deal with
the text
even the Hebrew I've talked to the
Hebrew scholar on this and I'm probably
going to bring him on to discuss the
specific topic of Genesis because this
is one of his sweet spots and we're
going to talk about how in the Hebrew
language
um it literally there's no way of
dealing with the fact that Adam was
there which is part of the problem but
all of that to say
that's not who God gave to the church
that that she was not a gift to to the
church
um so
now he's going to move into this quote
that he was saying there about the
unread books because you know Ellen
White's primary books are printed on
like those red covers or whatever and so
he's got the little joke there we
shouldn't call him the red books we
should call him the unread books
you know does it make a lot of
difference if we hold a book burning
ceremony in our backyard and burn all
these legalistic Ellen White books so we
don't have to look at them anymore or if
we have every one of her books that she
has ever written on our library shelves
in pristine condition because we never
take them down
doesn't make much difference does it
so we've got to decide what we believe
about this gift given to the Seventh-day
Adventist Church the law The Ten
Commandments we say the law is not
nailed to the cross the law is for us
today the law can be kept by Christians
but watch it now
if I were to ask for a volunteer to let
me follow you home with a video recorder
video everything you say and do of
relevance for the next 30 days and then
bring you back up here and bring you
before the people as a person who has
kept the law perfectly for 30 whole days
here's the proof
how many takers might I get today
perhaps not many because we remember
just what happened yesterday and how we
had to say Lord please forgive me again
man it's just like
it's just all anthropocentrism
you know you're supposed to be talking
about the gospel here and all I keep
hearing about is like inward facing what
are you doing what are you doing it's
you you you you you we're looking at
this if I followed you with a with a
tape recorder
um you you you it just really really
showcases for us how adventism and and
to be fair they're not the only ones
that are this way but it is just a
man-centered message
they they want to say no it's all about
Jesus it all revolves around Jesus no
that doesn't mean that you just insert
Jesus name willy-nilly in Adventist
Systematic Theology Jesus is a conduit
he is a means to an end to where you can
eventually get to a place where you
don't need him anymore he'll end and
cease mediating once he's gotten you
over the finish line and he's gotten you
there then he'll switch to being King
and and these other sorts of transitions
but Dennis I appreciate your honesty and
your forthrightness I wish your fellow
Adventists wouldn't try and play
semantic games and act like I'm a liar
or I have no clue what I'm talking about
when I point out how Central she is to
your movement
um you can't have adventism without
Ellen White it is not possible at least
not consistently
sure there's lots of fence that are sdas
or nominal sdas but for anyone who's
actually studied this movement and it's
Systematic Theology you know that you
can't have it without the other you can
we're not making this up I'm not talking
out the side of my neck and he proves it
so Adventists need to own up to this and
defend it otherwise get out of Dodge
leave adventism become a Christian if
you don't want to defend this then leave
it's part of adventism you can't have
your cake and eat it too I understand
that might be uncomfortable but that's
the facts you can't have one without the
other then we got the classic the law
wasn't nailed to the cross line I
mentioned this earlier and said
um I I wanted to to get into this
I've addressed this in detail other
people have as well because again folks
this isn't you know entirely unique to
to me
um or our platform but again
please check this out was the law nailed
to the cross
go through this they are dependent upon
these bad arguments to prop up their
system and make it look like a home run
but once you remove the caricature it
collapses
I do not know a single confession of
faith
that claims that the law was nailed to
the cross I've heard individual
Christians claim such regarding
Colossians 2. and they typically are
doing this to try and respond to the
Sabbath being done away with
but not official Source materials
maybe it's out there somewhere but that
isn't the historic Christian argument
and I wish Christians would stop using
these bad arguments
giving people like Dennis and other
Adventists unnecessary cannon fodder
because you don't need to say Colossians
2 says the law was nailed to the cross
to totally want the SDA Church's
position
there are way better arguments that they
are not prepared for because then as
you're aware Richard having engaged with
enough Adventists you then just end up
going around the circle of just proof
text back and forth proof text back and
forth and not actually looking at the
substance of what's being said and if
you catch that and I have it in the
article there for you folks if you catch
that it's like holy smokes this
decimates their entire system who cares
about trying to argue the Sabbath from
this passage understand what's being
said about the sin that being canceled
their whole thing falls apart which not
just that but it's completely consistent
not with just Paul's own theology but
the rest of New Testament theology
thoughts on any of that stuff I know
that was a lot
well yeah exactly I mean I think I
already addressed the issue of the whole
law being nailed to the to the Cross
earlier and you know to be honest I've
made arguments like that in the past but
as you pointed out it just
there's so much more we could get into
that that better refutes that and I mean
they will
call you out if you go down that road I
mean
that's that's not a road that is really
going to
to stand up I mean
as you pointed out it comes back to the
Sabbath and as you've been arguing you
know about the new creation and whatnot
really they have no idea how to respond
when you get into those arguments
they've not done this systematic work to
see where the story of the Bible is
leading where the direction is it's just
been the proof texting thing
yeah well and
well yeah oh it's it's getting long here
so I don't want to Sidetrack in that
because I can go on and on and on but
that is such a crucial crucial aspect of
discussion and that's exactly right if
you understand New Creation because Paul
leading up to that and again I'm not
going to get into all this now even in
Ephesians 2 when he uses phrases like we
are his workmanship that all this stuff
is getting into new creation and that is
a much stronger argument against
Seventh-Day sabbatarianism because
they're not prepared for it at all
because they're willing to concede and
admit because they know and that it's
true that Sabbath is rooted in creation
people shouldn't deny that people
shouldn't you know get in the tizzy
about that I we agree you and I agree
the Sabbath is rooted in creation now we
need to take into discussion both old
and new creation okay
but it's not just now point to Exodus 20
and then say see it's right there it's
rooted in creation and so therefore
Seventh-Day Sabbath and that that calls
it quits no let's look at the whole
picture and let's see about the new
creation that scripture talks about and
uh the form of these things like in
Deuteronomy 5 in comparison to Exodus 20
those sorts of things so all that to say
folks don't use the law nailed to the
cross argument like you said Richard I
used to use that argument as well when I
was a a more of a an infant in in the
faith and I'm not trying to dog on
people that do it's just you're giving
them unnecessary cannon fodder when
literally you can just totally want
their position by not going down that
sort of row because then you're going to
get caught in the inconsistency yourself
whether where they're going to basically
say well you're just saying that because
of the Sabbath and and you're going to
say well no I'm not and then they're
going to say okay well what about lying
well that's repeated in the New
Testament okay right so now you're back
at saying all this only because the
Sabbath you're going to say nine out of
the ten are repeated these just are not
good arguments these are not good
arguments
um Kane killed Abel
that is so it's just there's a number of
issues Joseph and and adultery with with
Potiphar's wife and and yet we're not at
Sonic yet so there's a there's a number
of issues there but nevertheless let's
continue with what he uh has to say here
where he Now talks about the proof that
the law can be kept by somebody with a
fallen nature
so where's the evidence that the law can
be kept by someone with a fallen nature
where's the evidence
uh you know that's the only evidence we
can call we can call upon not me not you
not even the great Heroes of the Bible
because everyone that has ever lived has
been a sinner at some point in their
life all men have sinned and come short
of the glory of God
the only one that is the proof the
living proof that the law can be kept by
someone with a fallen nature is Jesus
Christ and only if he took a fallen
nature
if he didn't take a fall in nature no
one has shown that to this day and Satan
is still winning the argument you can't
keep the law in a fallen nature that's
how important the subject is
and the Sabbath that's just the flag of
the law you hold up the flag of the
Sabbath as a statement I love God's law
that's what the Sabbath really is all
about a statement of
it's interesting that
in their false view of the law when he
says the law can be kept by a fallen
creature
what he means is with the help of the
Holy Spirit you can be given a
superpower to now keep the law
which is precisely in line with what
Ellen White taught how do we know this
quote
through Christ A Door of Hope was opened
that man notwithstanding his great sin
should not be under the absolute control
of Satan
faith in the merits of the Son of God
would so Elevate man that he could
resist the devices of Satan
probation would be granted him in which
through a life of repentance and faith
in the atonement of the Son of God he
might be redeemed from his transgression
of the Father's Law and thus be elevated
to a position where his efforts to keep
his law
could be accepted
close quote
that is not the standard
the law makes no provision for do-overs
or a second try because Jesus came
they think having a do-over with a clean
slate given and then continual seeking
to to keep it and confession and trying
your best when you fall short
to then have your sin transferred to
heaven for Jesus to blot out is somehow
keeping the law
nope not even close
doesn't work that way folks you break it
once it's over
and he said what Romans 3 says all have
sinned meaning it's game over
it isn't that Jesus can give you a clean
slate to try your best and eventually
you'll get to a sinlessly perfect State
when you're keeping it perfectly that's
not keeping the law Dennis
that is not keeping the law but
furthermore
this is all coming
through the lens of the great
controversy
which the Bible is then filtered through
where in the Bible Dennis does it say
that Satan is making the charge that
God's law can't be kept by any human
it doesn't
this is all your pre-earth origin story
coloring in the lines for you
folks he's just regurgitating this
quote this is from mind character and
personality Volume 2 page 564.
he that's Jesus came to demonstrate the
fact that Humanity Allied by Living
Faith to Divinity can keep all his
Commandments or all of God all the
Commandments of God
he came to make plain the immutable
character of the law to declare that
Disobedience and transgression can never
be rewarded with eternal life he came as
a man to humanity that Humanity might
touch Humanity while Divinity laid hold
upon the throne of God
another quote lift him up page 235 a
devotional book
quote Christ left his position in the
Heavenly courts and came to this earth
to live the life of human beings this
sacrifice he made in order to show that
Christ's charge or that's sorry that
Satan's charge against God is false
that it is possible for man to obey the
laws of God's Kingdom
close quote
Richard where does the bible say this is
why Jesus came and died to essentially
give people a do-over at trying to keep
the law
well yeah I mean I have the same
question all along is where in the world
does the scripture say this I can't for
the life of me
find it or remember it and I don't know
of anyone else who can I mean this is
getting into not Sola scriptura here but
Sola Ellen
yeah and it's just more again more great
controversy theme filtering the Bible
does not say that the Sabbath is a
statement of loyalty and you and I are
sabitarians yeah like the Bible nowhere
says this
Richard you just wrote an article for
the website on this the Christian
Sabbath versus the Adventist Sabbath
people you can check that out in the
search bar on the website Christian
Sabbath verse this Adventist Sabbath and
this is one of the major differences
that you pointed out nowhere does the
bible say that the Sabbath is a sign of
loyalty the Seal of God all this other
stuff like he said earlier oh it's a
sign of a person's commitment to God
Ellen White did repeatedly but nowhere
does the Bible say such it does it
doesn't and then they take this filter
and lens
to the Bible and they look around
they'll go to Ezekiel and they'll go to
Exodus and they'll say see it says it's
a sign between me and my people forever
that doesn't say it's the seal that
doesn't say it's a sign of loyalty
because
the Westminster framers for example
Christian sabbatarians down through the
years not Seventh-Day sabitarians but
crit not judaizing sabbatarians but
Christian sabbatarians down Through the
Ages have all agreed with that right
it's a Perpetual sign how does none of
them came to this conclusion and we're
talking about greats of the Christian
faith not just Joe schmooff in the
corner we're talking about the the large
majority
none of them came to this conclusion
that if somebody disagrees with me on
this they're lost
if somebody disagrees with me on this
they're not they're not a Christian if
somebody disagrees with me on this
they're not going to get the seal if
they're not loyal to God
so why is it that they're coming to this
conclusion oh right the great
controversy theme that's why
all right Health message all right up to
the top of the tree health
uh let's say you find a person on your
street who isn't doing so well
physically
you take pity on this person you say if
you will allow me to tell you exactly
what you're going to do with your life
or the next month
I will bring you into my home and we'll
get you fixed up will you do that he
says I'm desperate I'll do it he comes
into your home you teach him all the
laws of Health reform every one of them
he follows them Faithfully
and you know what the statistics are
even if a person has messed up their
life that following the laws of Health
Faithfully will give them extra years of
life on this Earth
and he does he has his extra years of
life and then he dies a natural death
and he wakes up
in the wrong Resurrection
at the end of the millennium
have we done him any good
we gave him extra years of life he
didn't get a heart attack that's what
health reform is all about isn't it
or not
not at all
Health reform is very simple the body
and the mind are one unit what effects
one affects the other
and it goes both ways if the body is all
messed up the blood supply is all messed
up and the blood supply feeds the brain
where we do our thinking and our
choosing and where God brings his
salvation calls to us
so if a person is physically messed up
he is mentally messed up at the same
time
so what is health reform about
to get the body in good shape to get the
blood supply in good shape to get the
brain functioning properly so that God
has a fighting chance to save our souls
so that God can talk to us and we're not
just in a fog in which we can't hear
anything at all
Health reform does not save
but Health reform makes it a lot easier
for God to save us
[Music]
wow wow
when I first heard that I I was in the
car I was taking my son to the park
I like had to double take there in the
car and I'm like can you seriously just
say that right now
before getting into the the bombshell
that he says there
the health message will give you extra
years of life on Earth
Richard true or false
false I mean don't even get me started
on that I'm just incredibly thankful to
the Lord that I got out of eating my
Adventist Diet before I
really became diabetic I mean if I ate
the way so I'm a type 1 diabetic and if
I ate that way now I'd be all over the
map with with out of control blood sugar
it was just you know
piling on carbs and carbs in fact I had
an an Adventist friend recently arguing
with me about that
that you know high carb is what you need
and it's like dude I can't do it it
doesn't work
give me a break yeah this like fall one
size fits all understanding of again
this goes back to the great controversy
theme and we're returning to Eden we're
going back to the edenic diet and like
these sorts of things that it's just
like that it's not what the Bible says
man that's your great controversy theme
clouding everything it's funny Dennis
has to resort to the claims of the Blue
Zone data which is skewed and biased by
the way folks and says if you follow
every principle of it you'll be
guaranteed more years on this Earth
Dennis then why does the Okinawa Japan
zone for example utilize pork
why does the uh Greek Zone incorporate
wine
both things that are completely off
limits according to the Adventist Health
message
but notice how weak and impotent the
Adventist God is
their message of Health reform is
necessary for God to have a fighting
chance to save a person's soul
I just like the anachronistic reading of
that
again the Adventist Health message
wasn't given until the 19th century
a fighting even just all the craziness
around God's sovereignty and and who
you're talking about here when you say
it's all that stuff aside
the message is novel to the 19th century
God was saving people long before then
just these anachronistic sort of things
that's just like how can you say such a
thing about God the Almighty
I guess I missed that in Paul's Damascus
Road conversion Richard
God and His God in his great Glory
manifest himself to Paul blinding him
knocking him down to the ground it's so
powerful Paul can't help but to turn to
the Lord in Repentance
what a patently absurd thing to say
but his great insight into how weak the
Adventist God is
or Gods I guess I should say they're
trying their best to save people but
have all these obstacles in the way like
whether or not you eat cheese or mustard
and drink tea
if you do that
they're unable to communicate to your
mind
because that's totally what Hebrews won
for example tells us about how God
speaks today he's speaking in your mind
and if you eat certain foods it's going
to be clouded it's like we jump into
like a quasi-eastern religion sort of
thing going on here
which in turn of eating you know cheese
mustard
it doesn't it keeps God from having a
fighting chance of saving your soul
totally laughable man for anyone who's
had a radical conversion
he said Health reform doesn't save it
just makes it a lot easier for God to
save us uh except Ellen White claimed it
was salvational
quote testimonies for the church Volume
7 page 136.
those who teach the principles of Health
reform should be intelligent in regard
to disease and its causes understanding
that every action of the human agent
should be in perfect harmony with the
laws of life
the light God has given on health reform
is for our salvation and the salvation
of the world
close quote
furthermore
she said it was a part of the Adventist
gospel
bit of a longing a long quote incoming
folks but notice this is what Dennis is
parroting
quote the health reform I was shown is a
part of the third Angel's message and is
just as closely connected with it as are
the arm and hand with the human body
I saw again I saw
that we as a people must make an
advanced move in this great work
ministers and people must act in concert
God's people are not prepared for the
loud Cry of the third Angel they have a
work to do for themselves which they
should not leave for God to do for them
he has left this work for them to do
it's an individual work one cannot do it
for another
having therefore these promises dearly
beloved let us cleanse ourselves from
all filthiness of the Flesh and spirit
perfecting Holiness and the fear of God
quotes from scripture there gluttony is
the prevailing sin of this age lustful
appetite makes slaves of men and women
and be clouds their intellects and
stupefies their moral sensibilities to
such a degree that the sacred elevated
truths of God's word are not appreciated
the lower propensities have ruled men
and women
in order to be fitted for translation
so after all that
Health message is the right arm of the
Gospel it's a work that needs to be
carried out with boldness you need to
know about disease and all this sort of
stuff you need to be equipped on this
in order to be fitted for translation
the people of God must know themselves
they must understand in regard to their
own physical frames that they may be
able with the psalmists to exclaim I
will praise thee for I am fearfully and
wonderfully made
they should ever have the appetite in
subjection to the moral and intellectual
organs the body should be the servant to
the mind and not the mind to the body so
again he is just parroting Ellen White
as though that is authoritative none of
that is in scripture her proof texting
versus out of context does not make it
so
David didn't say what he did with Ellen
White's novel Health message in mind
that unless you adhere to the Adventist
Health message God won't be able to
communicate to your mind and be able to
save you
that's what he'll try and label as
conditional it's just conditional
no no
it's not that you have to believe it to
be saved it's just one of the conditions
to participate in Salvation
but yes Dennis you guys do think it's
salvational
because it's a part of your guys's
gospel message and Paul tells us in
Romans 1 16-17 that the gospel is the
power of God to Salvation for all that
believe it
so with that in mind that's why I'm
always asking aventus what's the gospel
what's the gospel we had an Adventist a
couple weeks ago in the open mic who
called in
who I brought up their pillar doctrines
of their novel gospel message which
includes this and he was like well wait
you think that we we teach and believe
that you have to believe all this to be
saved yes because you're calling it The
Gospel and the Apostle Paul says that
the gospel is the power of God to
Salvation for all that believe it so
what is that message the evidence church
has labeled this as their gospel message
or part of it the health message so yes
that's what you're saying by calling it
The Gospel and that's my entire point
with this platform that isn't the gospel
that's not the gospel that that's the
point that's that's precisely the point
so yes Dennis don't tell people that you
guys don't teach it salvational
especially when you're going to go on to
say like we mentioned earlier we kind of
spilled the beans on this you're going
to go on to say that if God's revealed
something then it's it's salvational
so it's a it's a constant sort of
flip-flop that's going on here any
thoughts on that
um
yeah I mean I would just ask again you
know this is coming from the
denomination that loves to talk about
how their solo scriptura where in the
scripture do we find
all of this stuff you know that we are
to do so that God can speak to our minds
so that he can have this supposed
Fighting Chance to save us instead we
find the opposite we find Jesus saying
in Mark 7 it's not what goes into the
man that defiles him but what comes out
we find
Paul saying
let no one judge you in food or drink I
mean the examples over and over again in
the New Testament
Colossians 2 16 or not Colossians 2 16
but Colossians 2.
do not taste do not touch Paul says
these things have an appearance of
wisdom but they are useless in stopping
the Indulgence of the flesh
and so yeah
the New Testament seems to be exactly
contrary to the Adventist the purpose of
the Adventist Health message I mean
First Corinthians 8 8 just buries
everything he just said
because essentially what he's saying is
is that diet is what's going to bring
you closer to God Paul literally says in
First Corinthians 8 8 that food cannot
do that that and it's perfectly online
like you said with what Jesus says in
Mark 7 about what truly defiles a person
they won't always be like Jesus no he's
talking about hand washing there right
folks because they're talking about
eating and he literally says anything
that goes into a person into his stomach
and is expelled can't defile him
so it's perfectly in line but Richard I
think you're missing we're
Paul talked about what Dennis is talking
about here in First Corinthians 10
. we you and I guess have been reading
the amended version of the Bible because
in there when he was talking to the the
Gentile about the Gentile Meat Market
which more than likely would have had
Pig and those sorts of things there that
were sacrificed to to idols
when Paul commended them that it was
okay for them to do such practices
unless it was going to be you know some
sort of
um individual conviction upon their
their own conscience you missed the part
in there where he told them you know I'm
telling you that you can you have the
freedom to do this but if you do it's
gonna be Cloud your mind and then you're
not gonna be able to hear God speaking
to you so I think that's where we where
he got it from his first Corinthians
chapter 10. but nevertheless okay now
he's moving into our our last segue out
here regarding SDA standards and Satan
being in incredible communicator
standards of the church and I'm talking
again about all of them let's say that
you listen to your pastor and do what
your pastor says 75 of the time and then
you listen to your favorite TV
personality and do what he or she says
the other 25 of the time who's going to
win that little tug of war
I'm afraid your pastor is on the losing
side because we got this fall in nature
don't we
so what is going on here is Satan a good
communicator
does he know how to reach through to our
minds even when we don't know he's
reaching through to our minds does he
know how to get behind our will and
choice faculties to the emotions
he's a good communicator
is God a good communicator through the
Holy Spirit
so we've got two Master communicators
both trying to convince us of the
rightness of their ways every day of our
life they're trying to convince us that
they're right
standards what are they for
if your standards are lifted up high
you know what you can actually do you
can shut Satan's voice out of your life
in a whole bunch of ways
wow
Satan is a master Communicator in
comparison to God almighty
if that isn't the most SDA thing ever I
don't know what is it is a perfect
example
of how to use the words of Ellen White
his satanic Majesty is always elevated
what a ridiculous statement
both are trying to convince us of their
ways
Dennis read Romans 1-3
no the Fallen man is naturally hostile
to God cannot seek for God is a hater of
God who cannot do any good by Nature a
child of Wrath and so on this idea that
man is some neutral agent and Satan and
God are tugging at every human being
pulling them in two different directions
and man's the final Arbiter is not at
all biblical
look at it folks
Romans 3.
Adventist Church just has such a bad
anthropology
this is Paul writing to to Jewish
converts
who after he explains what's going on in
the first two chapters regarding sin
would have been tempted to think
oh right but
I'm I'm an Israelite I've been given the
law
a level of superiority there ethnic or
national superiority
and so Paul's response after explaining
the things he does in say Romans chapter
1 about the downgrade into sin and the
the slide that Fallen man is in
he says what then are we Jews any better
off
so again he's anticipating the question
of the the Jew of oh I'm a Jew I'm not a
gentile
he says are we any better off no not at
all
for we've already charged that all both
Jews and Greeks that's a Biblical way of
saying
all people
are under sin as it is written now he
quotes from the Old Testament
none is righteous no not one no one
understands no one seeks for God
all have turned aside together they've
become worthless no one does good not
even one their throat is an open grave
they use their tongues to deceive the
Venom of asps is under their lips their
mouth is full of curses and bitterness
their feet are Swift to shed blood and
their path are ruined and misery and the
way of peace they have not known there's
no fear of God before their eyes
so no
the Adventist Church or sorry
the Apostle Paul
did not have the idea
the Adventist Church does sorry folks I
got uh
hang ups here on uh
on my end regarding
a couple slip-ups
no the Apostle Paul
did not have the great controversial
worldview that informed his
understanding of man
he explains to Jews who would have been
tempted to think we were given the law
we're not like the Gentiles who weren't
given that
but no they're in the same boat as the
rest of Fallen Humanity which is
naturally hostile to God this is before
he transitions in the next chapters four
through eight
to then explaining how the gospel is the
remedy to that problem
this is one of the weakest points of
administ theology in my opinion they do
not have a Biblical anthropology people
tend to get hung up on their state of
the Dead
with this topic but their understanding
of man's nature and and natural
disposition toward God
and that unless he's the first mover
changes the disposition of the
individual that was just described there
acting upon the will of a person bring
that person from being a slave to sin
they will continue down that path
there are already citizens of the
kingdom of darkness Satan's domain
that's the result of Adam being their
fallen Federal head that he bocked at
and scoffed at earlier
Fallen humanity is not in some neutral
state
that has too good communicating
influences it's almost like that
stereotypical like angel and devil on
the shoulder type thing trying to sway
them one way or the old one way or the
other
but also no Dennis the Adventist God is
a horrible communicator
the evidence of this is in the Miller
chart Fiasco
I mean give me a break God told her that
the number shouldn't be changed they
were as he wanted them then they changed
three times and the narrative became
well God had his hand over a mistake and
he was testing us present truth
he supposedly gave Ellen the day and
hour of Jesus is coming multiple times
she just couldn't quite get to seem to
get it
we've looked at all this before so I
won't rehash it it's on our website as
well but my goodness man no the
Adventist God is a horrendous
communicator
that can't they they
the Heavenly Trio can't even seem to get
their point across clearly which has
left you guys with a wake of
embarrassment and errors in your past
Richard is Satan the problem for man's
will
no and
you know in the midst of all this false
idea of you know the two just competing
for you
let's talk a little bit about God's
power to save so I think about what the
Lord Jesus himself said in John 6 37.
he said all that the father gives me now
think about that there's a people that
the father has given him and he repeats
that over and over again in the Gospel
of John it's repeated multiple times in
chapter six it's repeated numerous times
in John 17. look it up but he says all
that the father gives me
will come to me
and so what does that say about the
power of God to bring Sinners to himself
we looked earlier at Romans chapter 8
specifically verse 30 where it says
Those whom he predestined he also called
and Those whom he called he also
Justified
the structure of that of that grammar is
such
that all of the called are Justified
all of the predestined are called in
other words if you're involved in that
chain at one step you're involved in it
at every step there's no indication
in the grammar to allow
for somebody receiving this particular
call
and failing to be justified it's no it's
it's talking about a call where if you
receive it you're also Justified and if
you're Justified you're also glorified
I mean that's plainly what it says
and regarding the ability of man
in the same chapter I mentioned John 6
Jesus says in John 6 44 no one can come
to me unless the father who sent me
draws him
and he repeats a similar statement in
verse 65 where he said I told you
you cannot come to me unless it is
granted you
of the father
and so man is exceedingly weak you know
can't come to God without God taking the
initiative first but God is incredibly
powerful all that the father gives me
will come to me
that's what Jesus plainly says
yeah it's just another example of how in
Adventist theology due to the great
controversy theme everything is Satan's
fault
it isn't man's fault ultimately it's
Satan's fault
it's Satan's fault it's not Adam's fault
it's actually Satan's fault ultimately
it's Satan's fault that they sin it's
Satan's fault they're in the predicament
they're in and so on
Adventist it is not Satan's fault that
you sin
it is not Satan's fault that you sin
he said if you raise your standard real
high
it'll shut Satan out of your mind
yeah that sounds great and all Dennis
except unless you're born again United
to Christ he already has your mind
you're born part of his domain the
kingdom of darkness you're in Adam as
Paul says in Romans 5 which is a term of
headship just like in Christ is a term
of headship and Union with Christ all of
Fallen humanity is in Adam
again this is the false idea that man is
a neutral agent and it's kind of just
assumed
all right let's try and crank this out
here you can stop him from talking to
you you can move away from what he is
trying to say to you by what you don't
read what you don't watch what
entertainment you don't participate in
so that Satan doesn't have that full
access to your minds all the time
and if you've blocked Satan out of your
mind does that give God a little more
opportunity to talk to you
open up some channels of communication
that weren't there before
okay so that means that high standards
faithful standards give God a fighting
chance to save your soul
standards don't save you
but standards open a door for God that
would be shut otherwise if your
standards are low or missing
because Satan has full access to your
mind one hundred percent of the time
standards become vitally important you
see in this gospel not as a means of
salvation but as a participation a
cooperation in God's 100 percent work of
justifying you and sanctifying you
everything that he said
is behavioral
notice all the issues are strictly
Behavioral which again he mentioned that
at the beginning that there's no concept
of sin as a as a nature
and if you believe that that is the case
you can't then also believe it's
behavioral there's apparently some
mutual exclusivity for some reason
they said overcoming sin is as simple as
turning the TV off and not eating bacon
essentially in their eyes that's the
root problem
not the rotten fruit that's a result of
the real root problem which is that you
are by Nature a child of Wrath dead in
your sins and trespasses and need to be
brought to spiritual life and raised by
God which is an actual change in one's
nature it's not just some pithy Poetics
that Paul decided to employ in writing
Ephesians
but he's a closing off opportunities for
Satan opens up others for God to be able
to reach you
again the the impotence of the Adventist
God
no word is scripture given Inkling
of Yahweh being limited by such things
as your diet and sin limiting him from
being able to reach you again for people
who had radical conversions where God
regardless of the person's sinful
disposition radically change them by his
Sovereign freedom and his ability to
save for his own eternal glory
you just hear these things and you're
like
shoot
if that were the case I had never had a
chance
I'd have been I wasn't seeking for God
you know and I know everybody's
experience isn't the same I'm just
saying when I hear stuff like that as
somebody who had a radical conversion
it's just like
did that does not align at all with with
my conversion the irony of his statement
is that his standards are way too low
his standards of God's holiness his
standards of sin God's been demoted to
being like a creature Satan's been
elevated to be some legitimate rival to
God and communicate in the communication
Department
unless you do something that can open up
the doorway for God he's just stuck in
like a beggar status he's done all he
can he's trying his best but that's as
far as it can go
any thoughts on that before
transitioning here
oh again you know it's
it's easy to you know chuckle at it but
in reality it's just exceedingly sad and
obviously you know a person who's been
indoctrinated into adventism and not
known actual biblical Christianity
doesn't see the issues with this but
when you know the true God the true
Christ is he is revealed in the Holy
scriptures
to hear these things is just appalling
it is absolutely appalling you know that
God is
is just his hands are tied unless you do
this or don't do that
it's just
totally repulsive to to basic Biblical
teaching and and Christian reason
all right that's the gospel I understand
to be the gospel of the Bible the gospel
of The Seventh-Day Adventist Church and
here is a little statement that I think
is relevant for us today it is sad to
see the illusion further popularized
that such lifestyle issues as diet and
adornment come from a religious
perspective but our quote not a matter
of Salvation if the written counsel of
God addresses a subject it must be
salvation related or God would have left
it alone
wow that's a good principle
if the written Council of God addresses
a subject it must have something to do
with salvation or God would not have
wasted his time
it may not be the means of salvation
but it may be a condition of Salvation
or an a way to achieve salvation
or God would not have bothered talking
about it
well my friends that is what I
understand to be the gospel of the Bible
and what is unique about Seventh-Day
adventism and I go one step farther here
Satan's great objective as best I can
tell
is to destroy this gospel
he is content for you and me
to be Sabbath keepers
believing that Jesus Christ is coming
literally in the Clouds Of Heaven we
won't fall for Satan impersonating
Christ we're not going to believe that
there are ghosts around we're not going
to be tricked by Mary appearances around
the world we're not going to be involved
in all of these deceptions
but if we believe a false gospel
he's got us and he doesn't care if we
believe all the right things about the
Sabbath and the second coming of Christ
and the state of man after death
if we if we believe his gospel that it
is allowable to go on sinning in some
way until Jesus comes
then he's got us
no matter what truth We Believe In The
Seventh-Day Adventist Church
so as we saw
throughout this whole thing
he considers the gospel to be systematic
theology
but he says if the written counsel of
God addresses a subject that must be
salvation related or God would have left
it alone
I mean if that doesn't summarize why so
many sdas are confused sadly I don't
know what will everything is a gospel
issue
everything literally
and notice he doesn't just contain it to
the Bible but Ellen White's writings
fall under written counsel of God do you
catch that
yeah he said anything that falls under
the written counsel of God well that's
not just the Bible so all of what you
mentioned the the Mount Saint Ellen in
comparison to Mount Saint Helens which
is a fair comparison
yet five minutes ago he said the health
message isn't salvation related
so everything Ellen White gave Counsel
on and what scripture gives Council on
it's all a gospel issue
this showcases they don't understand the
gospel because again Paul says the
gospels the power of God to Salvation
for all that believe it
it's not every single Doctrine revealed
by God it's a specific distinct message
the average lay Christian who isn't a
theology nerd
is not getting into systematic theology
they simply love Christ serve their
local extension of his body with their
giftings they worship him they love
their family they're involved in their
local sphere
and they know the simple gospel that
person's able to tell you the gospel the
person at my church
who knows not a lick about Systematic
Theology they fit the bill that I just
described yet they can still tell you
the gospel
it's not a bunch of this this whole
system of all this stuff and admins do
this all the time man and you run into
this because if you're a calvinist you
have to deal with this added uh
caricature that they're gonna throw of
well that's Calvinism that's that's just
because you're a calvinist that's so
anytime you disagree with them it's well
it's Calvinism and so they see
everything as a systematic theology
it's like yo homeboy
Calvinism is not the gospel
because people who are not Calvinists
can still be Christians because they
have the same gospel and the same God so
it's not Systematic Theology and that's
the key even the lay Christian can
understand the gospel
I mean just apply this historically
I get that in adventism the church was
truly born in the 1800s
but man those poor medieval Christians
those poor medieval Christians who
didn't have Systematic Theology the poor
Christians in the 600s 700s Etc
but he said this is just like whenever I
hear this I'm always like well no wonder
they have the persecution complex when
you say stuff like this Satan's greatest
objective is to destroy the Adventist
gospel
think about the greatest adversary
you know the greatest evil in the world
you know whatever title you want to say
his greatest mission is to destroy the
Adventist gospel I mean the irony
Dennis Satan is the originator of the
Adventist gospel
he's not trying to destroy it he
employed it
he said if we have a false gospel Satan
has us
Dennis you have a false gospel
your gospel contained nothing about the
person and work of Jesus
the literal base layer of the gospels
not predestination it's the person and
work of Jesus
your gospel had nothing about the good
news of Jesus Christ
it was a remedial presentation of a
Systematic Theology of libertarian
Freedom contrasted over and against
predestination
it was basically a service presentation
of the pelagian controversy with
Augustine
you didn't even present the gospel sir
agree again great controversy Paradigm
informs everything
you have a novel gospel that was born in
the 1800s your own Publications openly
State the apostles didn't preach it the
church fathers didn't preach it the
reformers only you guys it is not
Apostolic in origin
that means it's not the once for All
gospel that Jesus Christ revealed to the
apostles that's been handed down for us
today
Satan already has you my friend
the root issue of all this is the great
controversy worldview because even the
two trees that you tried to present and
say well this is the Christian one that
some Adventists have tried to adopt and
then in the fruit of the branches tried
to you know make it work and
no Dennis there's an underlying thing
that connects all of you guys
the great controversy world view because
even in the second tree that's supposed
to be the Christian tree you're
caricaturing it because you're even
reading that through the great
controversy theme
any thoughts on that before we move to
the very last section in his sign off
oh yeah I mean totally spot on you know
great controversy stuff overlaid on all
of this
um just assumed I I mean
again show me from the Bible where all
this this whole great controversy world
view is
um
I mean the scriptures totally decimate
this whole thing that you know God is
trying to prove himself the good guy and
Satan the bad guy you know he's just
he's trying to win you over but Satan is
winning you over
you know underlying all of this is a
fundamental distrust of the character of
God the biblical God this whole idea you
know that the creature needs to see if
the Creator is good that you know we as
sinners
get to make decisions about what God is
like
I mean that's that's what underlies the
whole thing that's really the foundation
is a lack of trust in the character of
God
and I would just say Adventists God is
good he is the objective standard
there is no other
he doesn't have to prove to you anything
he's holy God
your sinner
this whole thing is absurd this whole
great controversy that you know God is
trying to show you that he's the good
guy and Satan is the bad guy
no God is God
he is objectively good take him or leave
him as he is
and so I believe that this is Satan's
last attack upon God's Remnant people
just before the second coming of Christ
destroy their gospel negate their gospel
compromise their gospel make sure that
my understanding of Salvation takes
preeminence in their lives
and he's got us
and this is the great great danger of
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church today
is a compromised gospel
everything else every problem that we
have in the church today no matter what
controversies we have flow out of that
that is the root cause which is why I
don't spend much time talking about
symptoms of apostasy and there are quite
a few of them
but I want to talk about the root cause
of apostasy
and that is living believing and being
persuaded that a gospel is not quite
what we thought it was
it's a it's an easier gospel it's a
gospel which is more comfortable to me a
gospel I can live in and still sin a
fair amount and I'm still okay
all right
that is my understanding of the gospel
and here is where we're going to uh
kind of adjust a little bit up to this
point I have not said anything that
should give you any evidence that what
I'm saying is true because all I have
given you are my opinions have you
noticed that
I haven't opened the Bible I haven't
given you any inspiration at all to
support anything I said so I'm going to
ask you to do do something don't believe
what I've said because I've said it
because if you do you'll believe someone
else because they say it
believe it only if you have studied it
for yourself and know for yourself what
is true
so we'll spend the rest of our time
during this seminar opening up the word
of God to see if these things are so
all right so that was all of it
so Satan's gospel is what he presented
as the mainstream Orthodox Christian
Gospel all that to get to
that's Satan's gospel
and when he presented as the Adventist
gospel is the real gospel
thoughts on that Richard
well yeah I guess in his mind then
everybody is of Satan everybody is wrong
except for Adventists of course and we
know that's that's the mentality but as
you've pointed out you know they're on
record admitting that this gospel they
preach this gospel they've been given in
the 1800s
nobody preached it before nobody was
given it before it's been uniquely given
to them
and
it doesn't take a lot of thinking to
realize the Apostle Paul said if it's
any gospel other than the one we
preached those guys back there 2 000
years ago in the beginning of the
Christian church
let him be a cursed even if an angel
from heaven brings it you know Ellen
White's
accompanying Angel for example does that
ring a bell
a little bit
I mean so they're on record saying this
is a unique gospel to the 19th century
you know it came through the writings of
Ellen White their helper that you know
had Angels revealing this stuff and yet
the Bible tells us clearly warns us
against this sort of thing
that you know even we or an angel from
heaven as Paul says should deliver to
you a different gospel than the one we
preached let him be accursed and so by
their own admission they have a
different gospel
that is under the curse pronounced in
Scripture
it's sad
um I'm gonna comment on that actually
after I let you go because this went
really long my friend thank you for
being here I know that this was a lot so
thank you for giving us some time I
think this will be beneficial for people
to see
um nice to just be a little bit more
relaxed as well and just kind of spend
the evening together talking about some
stuff that I know that you and I are
both passionate about any last thoughts
that you want to share I'm going to let
you go and then I will do our sign off
if you don't have anything else no
pressure you don't have to say anything
else I don't know if there's anything
you want to plug or anything like that
but uh if not no worries I would just
conclude by saying the gospel is not all
this systematic
theology it's not you know the mechanics
as interesting as as you know the
mechanics of theology are the gospel is
Jesus Christ it is the person of Jesus
Christ specifically it is Christ given
for you in his life his death his
resurrection if you will have him
he
in his entirety will be yours and you
will have everything you need in him
for now and for all eternity you are
complete in him as scripture says and so
realize that and if you haven't
given yourself holy and solely to Christ
please do that and know the joy of the
Lord
Amen brother thank you for being here
I'll be talking to you I'm sure we'll
have to do something like this again
um maybe on another preview video or
maybe a different topic but we'll be
talking so again thank you for being
here
all right thank you
all right folks did you notice there at
the end
preemie said
this entire time I haven't opened up the
Bible
or cited any inspiration
it's just been my opinion
now I know I said at the beginning this
isn't going to be a Bible study it's
going to be a comparison because in the
later videos in the playlist he's going
to get into Bible study and that sort of
stuff but
Dennis it wasn't just your opinion
it wasn't just your opinion
and this is the thing I hear constantly
from SDA leaders
you know we just looked at it a few
weeks ago Mark Finley
in my imagination
I see Satan holding a diabolical council
meeting in outer space somewhere like oh
you don't dude you just red on white
you're literally and then we like whip
it out it's like no dude you're
literally just influenced by Ellen White
why are you saying this as though
you didn't get this from somewhere
it's like these little subtle things and
I'm like why are you guys like that
even here previews like we shouldn't shy
away from Ellen White well dude you
didn't just give your opinion tonight
you literally were just regurgitating
Ellen White it's like I'll listen to
these SDA pastors people will send me
stuff I respond to videos typically that
people are sending me or that sort of
thing it's like I just start listening
wherever I may be at and I'm just like
no dude you're quoting Ministry of
Health right there no no you're just
paraphrasing sons and daughters like no
you're just paraphrasing faith in works
that's great controversy that's Christ
and it's saying like
so for somebody who I'm not saying every
person has to be at that level folks I'm
not trying to say I'm some sort of
expert even
but for somebody who understands it at
that level to hear you say these things
like no it's just my opinion or I
imagine no no you were citing Ellen
White because at the end of the day
that's where all of your guys's theology
is coming from
now of course I'm gonna have all the
sdas that are like I can prove all my
theology from the Bible alone and okay
yeah okay
I understand what they mean but
you're not in the discussion at that
point folks because people like Dennis
Priebe Stephen Bohr Doug Batchelor Ted
Wilson these people know how
foundational Ellen White is to the whole
thing
so the point being is Dennis no it
wasn't just your opinion
it was you're paraphrasing of Ellen G
white that's what was actually going on
but I want to Circle back closing
thought here closing question to leave
everybody with
if you weren't here in the beginning
the very opening statement
that Dennis gave
adventism is worth dying for he said
is adventism really worth dying for
folks
yeah
that's like that's a bold statement
I don't doubt that he seriously believes
it I'm not you know calling any of that
into question but
I've been since it's worth dying for
no
Mr privy adventism's not worth dying for
Jesus Christ is worth dying for it
and I know that you're going to say well
Jesus Christ started it you know
which that even misses the point
Christ is worth dying for sir
not a false gospel that was born in the
19th century that Paul says it's under a
curse and anyone who proselytizes it is
under a curse from God
it says atonement didn't take place at
the cross no sins were canceled at the
cross Jesus is still in heaven dealing
with sins
all the contradictions
the history
that's just riddled with errors and
plagues started by christological
Heretics
sir the fruit of that is rotten
it's rotten
it's not worth dying for
and what you presented tonight is not
the true gospel
neither of those trees are the gospel
Richard mentioned it
ultimately comes down to Union with
Christ
not systematic theology
a person becomes United to Jesus Christ
not by understanding all the mechanics
around Original Sin
believing original sin is not the power
of God to Salvation such that if you
believe in original sin that's the power
of God to Salvation
whether it's true or false
that's the point is that it's not the
power of God to Salvation
yes the person at my at our church
who doesn't check off this pietistic
checklist that you guys have created
that you claim is well that's Christian
Living that's being like Jesus if I read
my Bible every day and if I go to church
every Saturday and and I check the the
box of all these things that's pietism
sir
that doesn't mean you're United to
Christ by faith
and I'm not saying you shouldn't be
reading your Bible we're blessed to live
in a time where you have such ease of
access to it and you're going to be held
accountable to that of course
but this idea man that if a person's not
doing that
they're not a Christian
or they're not they don't understand the
gospel it's just nonsense
and the reality is is the vast majority
of Christians are that way
they're not systematic theologians sir
they don't understand half the stuff
that you're even getting into tonight
they may have an opinion on it Etc
but if that's the gospel that's the
power of God to Salvation and then you
said everything that God has revealed is
salvation on
if you're an Adventist
understand this is why you may have been
confused
this organization has set you up to be
so I was as well I remember when a
Christian first asked me to share the
gospel with them and I was like uh
because I didn't unders I was like oh
man I don't have enough time to get into
all this he he cut me off in my
presentation poor guy we were eating
lunch
he had to cut me off
to say hey I don't mean to be rude
can I share something different with you
he gave me the simple gospel he had his
Bible there he gave me the simple gospel
message
I wasn't converted on the spot
but that stuck with me because here it
is
14 years later 13 years later whatever
it is
haven't forgotten it never will
always stuck with me in stark contrast
to this crazy convoluted Systematic
Theology of just all this stuff man
that's not the gospel Adventist we want
you to come to know the true Christ and
his gospel yes it is that simple yes it
is a simple message
just like the Philippian Jailer what
must I do to be saved sirs
conviction came over them
what must I do to be saved believe on
the Lord Jesus Christ
they didn't go into a doctoral
dissertation on original sin and
predestination and Calvinism and
arminianism and
no no
the gospel is a simple message it is a
simple message
you can be forgiven and in Dennis's eyes
he's going to say well forgiveness just
let off the hook no that's not what
we're saying when we say forgiven
you can be made a new creature in Christ
today yes a real ontological change in
your being and any person who's had this
encounter with Christ and has been born
again they know what I'm talking about
it's a glorious thing
because when it happens it happens
and once it clicks and you understand
you're United to Christ by faith there's
nothing I can add to that there's
nothing I can take away from that I'm
secure in that he's going to keep me
the days where I fall short he chastises
me
like a good parent doesn't disown me
because my eyes are not faced also
inward
a lot of what you were saying tonight
Dennis was inward face
it's all about you you you what are you
doing what does it look like with you
and you
this is where the weak sacramental
Theology of adventism comes in as well
when you're not doing the Eucharist
weekly
you're not well there's just a whole
number of issues with that
but that is the gospel to your senses
it's a sign and seal of all the promises
that a person has by being united to
Jesus Christ by faith you need to be
seeing that and partaking of that weekly
and be reminded it's outside of me
it's not internal to me
it's not about developing this inward
righteousness it's not to say that
there's not change that takes place we
looked at the Westminster Confession on
sanctification tonight
so I'm not downplaying that either but
this idea of this constant focus on this
inward disposition and
I mean he's one of these folks that
Christ hasn't returned because there's
not enough sinlessly perfect people
living the Adventist message on Earth
yet at the same time the Sunday law is
not a a conditional prophecy
so Christ can return to any moment but
the Sunday law is not a conditional
prophecy
so it has to happen before you return
all that to say folks
please read the article on our website
to go on there and type in Union with
Christ
that's the core of the Gospel folks
the good news about the person and work
of Jesus that by faith you can be United
to him
he'll change you he'll make you a new
creature
your war with your sin yes your whole
life
and unlike Dennis is claiming
glorification doesn't happen here yet
that's something that happens after the
sanctification period
they're trying to lump all this
justification sanctification
glorification all into this one over
realized period
but go on there read that article please
if you stuck with us this whole time
four hours absolutely crazy I did not
anticipate going this long I know I've
said this like the past three weeks I
really did not anticipate going this
long but I'm glad we were able to
respond to all of that because I think
it was beneficial
um
and next week taken off from live stream
we'll have some other content that's
going up uh in the interim and then
we'll be back the following week
test the profits going to be here so
we're going to be looking at Holy Batman
plagiarism
um with test the profit and we're going
to be doing a uh big old stream
dedicated to the evidence of Ellen
White's plagiarism
so two weeks from tonight I believe
that's the the 28th
but as always Adventists our call is the
same call to you that you have to us
come out of her my people you know who
I'm referring to when I say her come out
join the true Christ uh or join the true
church by uniting yourself to the true
Christ by believing his gospel as always
until next time God bless
[Music]